i want to let you know that uh today's
episode is brought to you by liquid
death
it's a mountain water it's good
today's episode is brought to you by
magic mind
it is the anti-procrastination
beverage if you uh you want to get in
flow state
go on and get into it they can help
magicmind.co
promo code theo for 10 off today's guest
uh is a friend of mine and he has a new
special
uh that will be march 4th live
the jump cut special you can get tickets
on his website
joshwolf.com uh today's guest
is comedian josh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know what's crazy is that like when
you go on tours like that
you know you you don't think you're any
different
from the first day to the last but like
when you get off the road for a week
you're like oh
sh shh who was that dude at the end of
that you know what i mean
like you slowly morph into beth always
tells me she's like i
i don't really like you after those long
she's like you're a different person
because
you're used to doing everything that you
want
at the whim when you want to do it
you're living on your time with your
vibe
yeah and you come home and you [ __ ] it
up you get like you got responsibility
but like also
there's other people in your world now
yeah who expect things from you but
you are so used to on the road
everything you want to do when you want
to do it is when it happens
yeah i think you know be yeah i think
being on the road honestly this realize
is probably the most
organized time of my life
like i am unor i'm almost grateful
sometimes that there's the road because
it's like
then i know a place i have to be i have
some
a little bit more responsibility you
know
there's no doubt this quarantine has
done a couple things for me
one it has highlighted
that i'm not as mentally
i'm not emotionally in as good a shape
as i thought i was
dang because i've had more time
with my own brain do you know what i
mean it hasn't been like
the road had me on a schedule oh yeah
the road again it offers a lot of get
out of jail free cards it's like oh
shit's bad at the house
yeah i'll be in cedar rapids
you want to go to des moines this
weekend i do yeah
oh this relationship's falling apart oh
well i'm in buffalo thursday through
sunday
it's true yeah but also like with more
time
to be introspective
i realized oh some of these things
because of my schedule's been so hectic
some of my some of my shortcomings i've
really covered up
really with yeah man yeah
one thing that this year has shown me
like because i will tell you
i'm at the same time mentally healthier
than i've ever been but also
unhealthier because i've i've really sat
with myself
so i've peeled back more layers which
feels healthy but then i'm peeling [ __ ]
back and being like oh you're [ __ ] up
this onion's dirty yeah yeah this onion
needs to be
washed you know like this layer this
onion has tears in it
it looks like people been crying on this
onion yeah it
so but it's been it's been interesting
man you know it's been interesting
the one thing i've discovered the most
dude is that a lot of times
the happier i appear
it's a it's me covering up for something
oh damn because i'm a super happy
optimistic dude yeah you always seem
like the happiest dude
and so what i've looked at is sometimes
when i'm really doubting myself
or really struggling with something
personally
i'm extra happy now i'm i am an
optimistic dude and by nature
i i like lifting people up like i think
the more successful all of us are
the more the better it is for everybody
like all that [ __ ] but there's some
times where i
put on that face when inside i'm like
the more i hate myself the happier i am
to other people really
it's what i've just found over
quarantine dude it's been
manners real damn that's interesting man
i'm trying to think about that as you
say it like i wonder if i
the more i hate myself the happier i am
to other people
it's my defense mechanism you know yeah
no
i didn't know that but you always seem
like you know you're always
usually like really affable and you know
friendly guy
um what's your but like what's your like
when you are in a bad spot
so some people disappear they were they
remove themselves
from other people right that's their
defense like
i have a family member that like when
they disappear i'm like oh they're
something bad's happening yeah do you
know um but
it's the opposite for me i want to show
you how well i am so i'm
i'm in front of your face showing you
how good i am do you know what i mean
yeah
that's interesting man i wonder what i
wonder what way i am i think
i don't know i i feel like i'll probably
be i'll get more down in the dumps
probably
you know or i'll get i definitely get
angry
like if things aren't going good i'll
get uh i've found recently in this past
year definitely
anger is something that i've had to deal
with more than ever do you do you find
yourself
like can you when you get really mad at
like inanimate objects or the gps you're
like oh yeah the things
like when you're screaming in your car
at the gps oh yeah
when a [ __ ] is gonna it's just like the
laundry room door
yeah yeah yeah yeah all right
[ __ ] i'll say things like that
to it
like it's been building up his plan
against me and it just got finally edged
me again
finally you guys are about you and the
door gonna have it out once and for all
i can kind of understand that video
where the guy just throws that screen
out into his yard you know
when they have that video can you find
that sean also that one that you know
one of my favorites is that dude that
the door dash or the grub up dude who
goes walking up the steps and he slips
with all of his food that he was
delivering and then he just picks up the
cup and throws it at the house
just for you
it's already empty but he's just he
wants one last he's got one last hurrah
yeah
he wants to get it that's it right there
so i'm going to click on that
yeah this yeah this is this is one of my
favorites yeah
he's been working all day because also
we this kid looking at him oh dad's a
hero
and he's like this i can't even get back
in
it's hot out there what's he thinking
right now
okay i'm gonna she wants me to fix this
[ __ ] he's
he's doing his best to keep it under
control right now
hey praise god baby let me tell you my
favorite part about that yeah
i like seeing angry dude lift [ __ ] above
his head before he breaks it
you know
that that is an angry movement right
there such a caveman move
yeah and and you know what like he
really wanted to i'm sure when he looks
back at this video he's not going to
like the way he looked
i'm sure he wanted to look smoother yeah
when he was wrecking it
or when he was throwing it off the you
know none of it looked great
you know no it'll make him probably i
bet i would i wonder where that guy is
now like did he get in a crossfit did he
get into yoga
did he get into did he start a screen
nowadays you could take a viral video
and literally start a screen door
throwing
competition yeah or maybe the screen
maybe that child is so embarrassed of
his father he's like i'm gonna work out
for the rest of my life maybe
maybe maybe that kid looks at that video
a couple times and like look at this
he couldn't even smush a screen door
this homer said
but the you know what that screen door
the only thing more frustrating to me
besides not being able to put it up
is you know the when you had the
headphones that had the wire
and you would knock the you would knock
it and pull the earbuds out of your ear
nothing made me want to strangle another
human more especially at the gym
yeah when you're working out you just
knock it and both of them fall out of
your ears you're like
because at the gym i don't like i don't
know about you i need to find
uh motivation so i'll pick
one person to hate at the gym
i'll pick out their shorts like i
[ __ ] hate those shorts [ __ ] allen
yeah like alan like alan's wearing asics
[ __ ] allen you know and i'll just stare
down the whole time i've had a guy walk
up to me like
do we have a problem i'm like nah i'm
sorry i just i had to i picked somebody
to hate
yeah when i left it's interesting to
really have like a um like an adversary
i guess like a motivation like like why
why is he wearing jeans
and a wife beater and and you know that
like like it's an outfit like he's
wearing acid wash jeans
and boots and a wife beater at the gym
and he's doing pull-ups and you're like
that's a lot
i [ __ ] hate that yeah i think i'm
trying to think
if i'm at the gym man i think i used to
feel more competitive at the gym now i'm
just like
i'm just happy to be in the gym like um
yeah i don't do as much weights these
right now so i'm just doing more yoga
and stuff but i guess i feel like
when i'm in there um i try to look at
the chicks but a lot of chicks now
that everybody wears headphones now so
you can't talk to any chicks
uh so then also if you get recognized
it's always by dude so it's like
you end up having to talk to a bunch of
dudes the whole time you know which is
great
yeah but it's not chicks no no no and
you know like i don't want
i hate it when people stand around and
they'll watch you do your set
waiting to talk to you you're like oh
man i'm having a hard time working out
with you just staring at me bruh you
know what i mean like
yeah can maybe we can meet up the worst
is the is the
i didn't want to bother you like they
walk you follow you in the locker room i
didn't want to bother you during your
workout
so you thought dick in hand was it
better yeah this is a good time yeah
yeah
this is a better time to jump in i sat
next to me at a restaurant the other day
and sat right and he talked he tried
nine different ways to talk to me man
and finally i said hey man i'm just
trying to watch some bass i'm just
trying to watch a basketball and chat
with my friend i had to just
it was just too much man he was just
pouring out his life story it was just
really sad and like
i get it sometimes but this dude was
also pretty wasted i think
so that makes it tougher i i am not one
of those dudes that like
i think you talking to me comes with the
job
i think like if you see me out
especially us it's different man i think
if you're tom cruise right tom cruise on
a big screen
so the difference between seeing tom
cruise he's a movie star you leave your
house
to go into a dark room so if you see tom
cruise at the airport you're like
there's tom cruise but you're not gonna
go up and talk to him
because he doesn't play tom cruise he
plays all those different roles you're
theovan
yeah you talk about your personal [ __ ]
so they feel like they know like you're
oh right do you know what i mean they
have an attachment to you that they
don't have to tom cruise
right so i get it when people come up at
the bar or come up because they already
feel like oh i know that dude oh yeah
you know what i mean i totally get it
yeah podcast
podcast listeners and podcasters and
everybody there's definitely more of
like a
family sense kind of i think it's a
relationship
the thing is this guy that i ran into i
don't think he knew me
i think he was just a drunk guy you
could literally see that he went from
person to person and people just kept
sending him away
he's like everybody i know died in a car
accident
and i'm like oh and you were like how'd
you get out like
i bet they just told you that bro i bet
they were living
happily in utah you tried their numbers
because i think they still work yeah
i had a dude tell me once he um
had a couple missing teeth and he goes i
lost my teeth because my daddy ran over
me with a tractor when i was six and i
was like
what and basically i was like well i'm
gonna have to
this is a story i do need to hear you
know i'm so glad but like
one of the things that i do love also is
i
really love weird [ __ ] and the people
who follow me know
the one thing i do love is people share
their weird stories and their weird
pictures and their weird videos with me
that is something i can't get enough of
i just looked yo i just looked at a
bunch this morning that people sent to
me
i wake up every morning like oh my god
is any of it on your story or anything
uh i just posted one on my uh
facebook page about this dude and i have
to post the follow-up videos
this dude he had a growth in his earlobe
oh
and um i just genetic thing usually well
no this was a
it was like a seed like that something
they planted in his ear it looked man it
looked like like there was going to be a
palm tree
like it looked like well you know if you
bury some seed under your skin it will
actually sprout isn't that crazy
what here go down a little down down
further further further further further
further further further
there's more keep going further further
keep going
oh sorry maybe one more that's jacob
wolfe maybe one more
oh i don't know how far down that was
the guy who posts on my page apparently
maybe he posted it look at that damn is
that you yeah what do you think about
that dude
that's my first headshot ever first
headshot
ever wow what do you think about that
one man
as long as we got each other yeah dude i
mean i'm sorry
why didn't i get it that's an 80s sitcom
like that's kirk cameron
when was that do you think i can tell
you exactly when that was dude that is
1993.
there we go um oh it's 1993
the guy who took that picture theo so i
went up
this was a gay man oh yeah it always is
look i'll tell you this and this is a
like get wanting photos in los angeles
is a gateway drug to homosexuality man
it's basically yeah it dude this but
this dude was like hey
you know i came into his house and we
took a couple pictures and what does his
name start with
oh do you remember 93 well
i'm sure there's only i feel like it's
the same guy it's so long ago
okay i don't remember i would have to
look but i know that he was like hey i
have some
he was wearing a robe when i showed up
oh damn and um i'd always heard the
broad stories
and i'm gonna tell you part of me was
like man how come i've never been robed
before like what's wrong with me
like oh yeah i think that a lot i've
never had a stalker like i've never had
a female stalker like
it's like okay damn yeah all right i've
had one
her she goes by the name sandy wang um
she has a website out about me no way
yeah i think it's sandy wang.net
and um but i i can show you i have about
five
thou there it is yeah that's her this is
her artwork okay so this is how i got
put into this ready for this good art
so i'm out at a dog park in l.a dude
it's not that good and this woman was
walking her chihuahua and i had my dog
at the time
and she said can we take a little walk
around i had met her a couple times and
she seemed normal
and i was walking with a buddy of mine
and what kind of lady white lady black
middle asian woman and um
we take one lap around the park and she
said uh
you know the twin towers exploded
because the government found a video of
me masturbating in my living room and i
was like
oh now my friend was like hey i'm out
yeah but i'm like i'm in yeah yeah yeah
so she said she said will you
go to my website here and look at my art
i'm like yeah let's see how
she also has a website basically
dedicated to
a conspiracy theory about me dang and um
so she ended up going to jail dude
did you press charges she wrote me from
jail
and she said and the letter was super
like
well written and was she attractive was
she yes
okay okay okay and so she got arrested
because she said
mercedes-benz set her up she was walking
by mercedes and i guess if you buy a
mercedes
they start the car and they leave it out
front for you so you can just
get it right so she was like well why
would they have started a car and left
it out front if it wasn't for me
so she just took a car so she just got
in and drove away
and so when she got arrested she was
like the you know the system is against
me
and it's a it's an asian you know it's
an asian thing
and the police were like you actually
stole stole a car
so she wrote me from jail asking for ten
thousand no way
the the and what happened you hooked up
with her no
dude she this is like oh wow
this is her website yes yeah
uh so here's the emails this is the
second email i will probably not be
sending anymore anyone who says that
will definitely be something oh my god
lord dude so
look at that look at the subject oh this
3r sphincter [ __ ] rectum [ __ ] oh
come on this is too much man
really sorry what's happening in your
life but you've got to stop sending
these to me
thanks josh oh you emailed her back i
was just trying to to get out gracefully
because she was sending
the weirdest dude if i sent if i showed
you the
5 000 emails she sent me wow do you ever
see now were there images in the emails
too sometimes or no
one email was just a picture of the
house across the street from my house
oh wow i sent about 500 of these emails
to i had a friend of mine who was in the
secret service
and i sent it to him and i go am i gonna
die and he sent me back he goes no he
said she's
crazy but she's like crazy like russell
crowe beautiful mind crazy yeah
he said but none of this tells tells me
she's
um thinking about doing something
dangerous but it was crazy man this is
all
right this is all crazy writings
so was she do you in the end do you
think she was manic having like a manic
episode i had an acting class with a
girl who was having a manic episode for
like
six months on facebook and she would
post things about brad pitt
um she would post like
all kinds of crazy stories like that she
was involved in like
celebrities lives and stuff um and it
was pretty fascinating to read
but it was also really really scary you
know yeah
and then i think people that tried to
reach her like she would like
lash out at them in some of her posts
you know like my dad called me today and
it was just intense man i don't know
what you do if somebody's really sick
like that
i i don't know i can tell when she's on
her meds and not on her meds
if when she's not on her meds i get 10
to 15 emails a day
but they'll but i'll go three months
without getting any dude one day at my
house
on my home phone now we've always had a
home phone just because beth is like
just in case we need a home phone
but nobody has that number you know so i
get a phone call
my family has it i get a phone call and
i'm like hello and it's wang
it's worse than wang i go hello and they
said josh wolf i go yeah speaking
and they said this is i forget what his
name this is so-and-so so-and-so
the head of tom cruise's security and i
thought it was my brother and i just
said hey dan
[ __ ] you and i hung up two seconds later
same number
and i go dan we gonna do this like tom
cruise's security this is what you're
going for
hung up call back don't hang up i need
to ask you about sandy wang
now i know my brother doesn't know about
sandy wang and i know there are only two
people in my life who do know
me and beth oh and jacob because i
needed to be like hey if you see a short
little asian woman around the house
yeah get the [ __ ] out even though he'd
probably try to smash
jacob dude that dude is definitely
yeah he's about some [ __ ] i mean
listen he's at that age
he's at that age where he is still
willing here's exactly how it is
he is still willing to [ __ ] someone that
is extremely dangerous
yo we've all been that how old are you
i'm i would [ __ ] a stalker that's how
old i am
that is a 100 right that is an age you
know what
that's like i've always said you know in
high school
somebody would ask me we talk about deal
breakers and we got down to high school
i'm like i don't know if i had a
deal breaker in high school yeah like i
had a woman
a girl literally throw up on me
in when i was a junior in high school
but i was
thinking i was gonna have sex for the
first time oh yeah so i just told her
straight up
not i'll shower it off like not a deal
breaker for me damn but
she she was like are you kidding and i
said
no like damn yeah yeah yeah that's but
that's young
you don't know you think she's going
that way too you're like oh no
yeah let's get sexy let's get back in
there let's get back in the shower
yeah i think i've had let me think i've
had
let me think if there was deal breakers
oh wet mouth i dated this girl for a
little bit and her mouth was always real
wet
and like the lips yeah lips and a little
bit like a probably
two maybe half a centimeter outside of
the lips
and so it was like beautiful girl too
and so it was like oh this is really
cool but then it started to be like uh
oh and then she had like sign up kind of
a she smelled like a little her breath
had like a unique
smell that got worse as the night went
on progressively bad breath
yeah i was like progressively bad and
then i think you had to put her to sleep
to [ __ ] get it back to zero you know
and then
you know so you wanted to take her to
brunch it was that kind of girl you know
it was like let's [ __ ] brunch and
hunch you feel me you know what i'm
saying
that netflix and chill yo there was a
girl that i picked up when i was
in pro in high school i was at my
friend's house
um he had his he was his family had a
little bit of money and they had a house
on cape cod in the summer oh yeah that's
rich bro
yeah we we definitely did not have that
kind of dough and um
but we picked it dude i never even had
cod until i was [ __ ] probably 23.
you wore a cape though i did wear it
yeah yeah yeah yeah you're right
that's a good place you didn't wear a
cape so even even
this girl we were 17 we met her at the
beach
her breath was so bad when my buddy
brought
he was like we're gonna go back to my
house i was like what am i gonna do with
this girl's
breath he was like when we get back home
like just give her some food so i tried
to
i tried to convince this girl feed down
the breath yeah i tried to convince her
that we should both eat a teaspoon of
peanut butter
oh yeah i was like how about some peanut
butter and she was like what
she wanted doritos i'm like no no not
with that
not what's coming out of that mouth i
mean adding fuel to the fire yeah
no but a spoonful of peanut butter i
thought that's a good idea yeah it's
it's like
because breath you have to get something
to like well i'm okay with if somebody's
breath
is a little bad like if it's dehydration
breath like some things you kind of know
okay it's just this is a moment they're
going through
but the thing is if you get somebody and
you smell that it's internal
that they're rotting out or something or
they're you know they had a baby that
didn't hatch or so you know what i'm
saying you don't know what's going on
sometimes and somebody
some of these issues are deep rooted you
know what i'm saying and you know some
dogs can smell cancer bring that up sean
that's true what can dogs smell what
diseases can dogs smell please
by the way did you hear that they're
yeah stuff had a variety of types
including skin cancer
breast cancer prostate cancer definitely
believe that
yep bladder cancer and lung cancer
dude if you smell enough ass like dog
does you will definitely
two of those is a definite they for sure
know what a good ass smells like
dogs are famous for their sense of smell
this sense is so advanced they can smell
diseases or medical conditions
um they have about 220 million receptors
compared to 5 to 10 million in us that's
imagine being able to smell that good
imagine being able to smell maybe if the
neighbors are cooking would you rather
have that intense
sense of smell or sight
i think sight because smell here's the
thing that would deter
smell i think it would start to like if
you got into like mating situations or
sexual situations it would really
i think for me it would inhibit me
because i would get real nervous it
would make you know it would be like
you know the less i can smell i feel
like for sex the better
you know now it also amazes me
that a dog can um
they can smell that good and still want
to have sex that much
yeah it's almost just it's almost like
extraterrestrial really
yeah i think they are like high school
kids times 20 though
it's just pure animal instinct like yeah
you know i think all ass is good ass as
far as they're concerned i don't
i don't you know what i mean i don't
think have you ever seen a dog get to an
ass and be like oh god
yeah you know they're always like yeah
i'll take another sniff like this
there's no dog has ever been like ugh
that's not i can't do that
you know savage it's almost like they're
on cocaine you know because i feel like
if you're on cocaine you'll definitely
you'll smell somebody's ass more than
once
um here's a disease right here
narcolepsy is a disorder that affects
the ability to control sleep wake cycles
dogs can smell that how do you smell
narcolepsy
two trained dogs detected 11 of 12
narcolepsy patients using
sweat samples dogs can detect a distinct
scent from the disorder wow
that is crazy to me that's fascinating i
wouldn't want the sense of smell
mostly and here's our difference in ages
you're thinking sex
i'm thinking restaurants like there's
two i
i like my food right the less you know
about how [ __ ] goes down in a restaurant
because i've worked in a lot of
restaurants yeah do you know what i mean
yeah
you don't want to know what's happening
back there no you you just it's two
different teams
yeah yeah yeah restaurant is two
different teams yeah
yeah yeah it's the it's the bucks and
it's the chiefs
yeah you and you don't by the way and
the chiefs are doing their best man they
got a mixed guy back there they're doing
what they can they got a couple brothers
you know what i'm saying
you know what they're doing what they
can but
the bucks man the bucks are showing up
to eat
i'm saying and you know what else for me
like
i don't want to know how it got made
i don't want to know like don't don't
break don't
lift the don't open the curtain for me
don't show me that fourth wall nah just
make sure when it comes out
the plate looks clean yeah and the food
looks right
yeah because don't be like oh sorry he
dropped a burger on the ground we have
to make another one don't tell me that
yeah just actually pick up that burger
yeah and wipe that [ __ ]
because i'm not gonna know but now i'm
gonna think
every burger has been dropped on the
floor yeah they drop everything you know
what i mean like
just wipe it off we we you worked at
restaurants i'm sure you worked directly
i worked at a man
uh oh yeah and gross [ __ ] happens in the
kitchens
it's just it's like yeah i mean it's all
it's literally they're doing their best
to get food
out there yeah that's all they're doing
they're not nobody's a chef back there
in
95 or 70 places i love it i love it when
they're like when you ask a waiter and
you're like let me ask the chef i'm like
is there a chef back there yeah this is
again we're a cracker barrel brother
there's no [ __ ] let me ask the chef
yeah are you calling a chef because he's
wearing a hat because that you know what
i mean like i make eggs at my house too
you know dude i remember i used to work
i worked for this famous restaurant tour
this guy sam fox and this is when he
first started
restauranting and i want to say he was
just
managing at this restaurant and i worked
there and some guy that's got a little
scotty he uh
he looked like the um
chef from the muppets can you bring that
fella up sean i love that dude
and uh sean sometimes a little slow he's
also a tennessee volunteers fan so that
all checks out
sorry but they just the volunteers have
to be good
yeah that's awesome oh this dude yeah
i'm just joking
um and i don't i didn't even give him a
shauna mike to defend himself today
either so i shouldn't have said that
if you like sex or if you don't even
like it but you you don't you have to do
it
because you have a spouse or you have
somebody who wants
who wants sex from you you know and an
inmate
somebody well look bluechu.com
offers men a performance enhancement
for the bedroom or kitchen or basement
or
a commissary wherever you little inmates
are getting
nasty the chewables from bluechew.com
can be taken on a fuller empty stomach
now look i prefer to do sex on empty
stomach but that's just me
you know and that's also a vietnamese
trick
the chewables from bluetooth.com are
made in the usa none of those
india penis pills like i've been on make
your legs sweat make your body
feel real troubled after here's a great
deal
support the podcast come on we need
support
and you need good weiner visit
bluechew.com and get your first order
free
when you use promo code t-h-e-o just pay
five-dollar shipping
that's c h b-l-u-e-c-h-e
w dot com promo code t-h-e-o
i've used these weiner hitters man and
they work onward
after the year uh that i've been through
i'm gonna tell you that saving money
should be at the top of everyone's
resolution
list so if you're still paying insane
amounts of money every month for
wireless
well that's not saving money is it what
are you doing
switch to mint mobile it's the easiest
way to save this year
yep that's right the first company to
sell premium
wireless service online only that's
right
mint mobile lets you maximize your
savings
save your money just fifteen dollars a
month that's one five dollars
by going online only and eliminating the
traditional cost of retail mint mobile
passes
savings on to you use your own phone
with any mint mobile plan
and keep your same number along with all
your contacts
if you're not a hundred percent
satisfied mint mobile
has you covered with their seven day
money back guarantee that's your money
right back
switch to mint mobile premium wireless
service just fifteen
dollars a month what are you doing with
these other companies to get your new
wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
and get the plan shipped to your front
door for free
go to mintmobile.com t-h-e-o
that's mint mobile.com theo
cut your wireless bill to 15 buckaroos a
month
at mintmobile.com theo
so we had a guy look like this this dude
was probably four
nine right four nine a little scotty
they called them
and uh he had a chef's hat that was a
foot and a half tall dude to make him
[ __ ] whatever 5 11. and dude these
federales these like food federalies
rolled in one day kicked open the back
door and they busted him for
uh slanging illegal shrimp he had
illegal
illegal shrimp what does that mean u12
shrimp you look up u12 shrimp
what u12 shrimp yeah see what it says
jumbo shrimp u12 let's get an image of
those bad boys if we can i
i i don't even know that shrimp had
names oh yeah shrimp come in different
uh
colossal u12 white
so he was saying he had these but he
didn't caught shrimp 17
a pound he did he bought him illegally
early galley he went
black market black market shrimp dude
and they came in
bust and they put him on his knees at
that point on his knees he's two four
yeah
and they kicked his head off dude and
everybody was bro
when he lost his hat that's when he lost
his everything oh yeah
uh-huh did all the illegal receipts from
the shrimp come out from under his head
that's what he was keeping him yo
yeah this is the shrimp chart right here
so you got small
that's those 5160s but wait now
you got medium that's 4150s 3640s but
who's
selling u12s that aren't u12s you know
what i'm saying like who's saying hey i
got that u12
somebody man this is tucson arizona so
people rolling around with [ __ ] hot
shrimp and that's the thing
you got to sell them fast dude you know
what i'm saying you got to sell them for
the ice melts
it's that ticking time bomb of uh you
know it's that pop quiz hot shot of of
seafood
have you ever had uh food poisoning from
uh from seafood
i mean growing up in louisiana you had
bad fish oh right now
we had pretty good fish i think in our
area man i think a lot of the chinese
came through recently
or the viets came through and gave us uh
we look up uh vietnamese catfish takes
over america we look over that
you mean a different why are they eating
all of the
no this was
uh in 2012 vietnamese catfish captured
around 20
of american frozen fish market whoa in
2002 sorry in 2002 vietnamese catfish
captured 20 of american frozen food
market in 2012 this figure went up to 60
percent
most of the catfish you get if you go
somewhere it's not even american catfish
man
wait so they they fly it over from
vietnam or
they grow the vietnamese catfish here uh
that's a good question let's go to
catfish dispute up there at the top that
seems like
because that sounds realistic entry to
the u.s market after years of conflicts
a relationship between the us and
vietnam was eventually brightened up
when the embargo by the u.s to vietnam
was lifted in 95.
in december 2001 via signed a bilateral
trade agreement
um oh there it is imported from vietnam
u.s catfish is generally raised in
mississippi arkansas louisiana
in ponds increasing number of catfish
imported from vietnam
i wonder why i mean it's not
you can grow you can spawn as many fish
as you need to in these ponds
is it that much cheaper to fly them over
from a different country
that's crazy so then when you think
about it must be so then when you think
about that
with the shipping costs that's what i'm
saying and to keep it cold you have to
keep it cold or keep it in water
yeah that's what i'm saying like they so
and that goes back to
it's like when i when i used to eat
breakfast at places like shoni's
you know shoneys and yeah when they
would say steak and eggs for 3.99 i'm
like
leave the steak like steak by itself for
3.99 i'm not eating but steak and other
[ __ ] for 3.99 you know what i mean like
but that's the thing like what so what
are they doing to that steak what are
they doing to that catfish
to make it so cheap yeah i can't even
they must be maybe it's uneducated i
mean i have no idea or you know maybe
it's like getting raised in like just
like a damn little
fish kennel yeah that is so crazy my
sister has a bass in a freaking
my sister is pretty country they live
like within
you could uncle uncle who's that guy in
uncle reno who's that guy in
uh and what uh
uncle rico uncle rico could throw a
football from a cabela's to their house
right
oh yeah and uh oh yeah
and um they have a bass in a
uh aquarium that can't turn around it's
like
come on yeah so it just does this the
whole day that's crazy
oh but it's been alive for like seven
years man but angry
i mean i'm sure it's not fired up yeah
yo that bass is the only bass that would
straight up attack like that has got to
be
the worst life take me to the future
maybe that's where they copyrighted yeah
put me in the water
he's just pleading kill me
that is a tough way to go man it's a
crazy life
but the kids are healthy her two
daughters are doing fine so they just
you know
they don't change up the game man but
yeah so it's crazy a lot of it's called
whey fish i think are we fish let me see
what it says food labeling claims right
there
try or basa they started
so a lot of times it will say catfish on
the menu yeah
and you're not getting catfish and i
could taste it man when i first
probably about five years ago i started
noticing even in new orleans man i would
just notice
this catfish is real thin it's just
really yeah it seems like it's probably
a gamer you know it's like yeah yeah
it just did it it wasn't that thick yeah
yeah yeah and that's when i realized
that oh it was viet man it wasn't even
american
american catfish yeah i wonder what the
cost what is the cost savings can you
look that up showing what the cost
savings but if they're smaller fish too
because maybe that's it also maybe
you're getting a smaller fish
but still to to have them
sent on a [ __ ] boat has got to be so
damn expensive
the great catfish war rages on have you
ever done the
noodling i haven't done it we've had
that that young lady came on king in the
staying hannah
baron yeah the champion girl and what'd
she say what's the trick to that
she said just being tough really i think
i think the biggest thing is just
getting used to them biting you you know
like
it's basically getting your hands stuck
in something really hard
it's just pressure right it's not teeth
is that right but they're not
they're not gonna cut you open so you're
not gonna slit your wrist or anything
but they're gonna
it's gonna be spooky you know that's the
thing like
how are you with like where are you with
risk and adrenaline junkie and all that
stuff like is it is
is noodling something that you're like
i'd like to try that i would do noodling
me too i agree with you on that i would
do noodling but i won't skateboard
me neither not at this age yeah no
theo i hit the ground i slipped on the
ice two days ago when's the last time
you hit the ground hard
um young man oh i got body slammed
earlier today by a 65 year old as a jiu
jitsu how does that feel
it [ __ ] felt i felt like it dude i
was willing to be his grandson for a
second dude that's how weird it was man
it was intense
i mean you that jiu jitsu man it's
pretty hearty
yeah yeah pretty hard and you fell you
fell on the ice
dude i slipped and when i was right in
front of my house
going down the hill so my dog took off
this is you guys are
it's steep out there yeah my dog took
off and i slipped so when i was in
midair he kept running so he just
pulled me and when i landed dude
i landed so hard that i was like all
right
i know adrenaline's with me but i'm hurt
damn so as soon as i hit the ground i
started calling for beth
yeah i was right out in front of our
giant windows i could see her inside it
was like a scream movie you know when
someone gets killed
but the people inside can't hear him so
i'm screaming to beth
i can just see her but i i'm literally
and i'm trying to get on my feet but my
dog thinks i'm playing so every time i
get on my hands
he knocks my hands off [ __ ]
so he's knocking me down and uh i
had to crawl back up the hill because i
was wearing pumas
no traction i had to crawl and every
five feet i was crawling he would knock
me out oh it was
terrible i got cut up i got cut up on my
hands
it was his name harry styles what's the
dog's name yeah indiana jones
oh indiana jones yeah harry that's a
better name though
indiana jones man this dog has straight
up
lost his mind since he moved here and
what kind of dog is it let's see a
picture of it he's half pit bull
half of um half pit bull half
american bulldog let's see this dog
right here
there's an upside down picture of him
right
there oh damn
look at that dude oh it's beautiful yeah
this is a dog like that way
68 pounds dude um but he had huge nuts
that beth did not want me to take off
y'all took him off
she was like why she kept saying every
morning i would come down and she would
just be petting him but looking at his
nuts and i'm like
i said what that's the first sign of
[ __ ] somebody leaving you
when i asked her i'd go what's the deal
she was like why are his nuts so much
cuter than yours i'm like
what's that she goes yours are wrinkly
and like his are so smooth and tight
yeah he's got that good bag man but
listen man he was he's younger than me
you know
like i mean he's i got a couple years on
this dude that that's your guy right
there have you seen that video of the
dude
making a bong out of a bit out of a bass
oh yeah i've seen that guy this this
dude
dude
[Laughter]
tell me i gotta tell you it didn't even
work
that's your guy man i didn't realize
that is our guy that's your guy and this
is me
obviously that's my one of my that is
not you that's that is one of my first
head shots in l.a
look at that dude that ain't you yeah
that's me man
or is this in hold on is this uh near
the docks in new york in 1908
why do i look 80 in this first of all
literally looks like my grandfather
there is no serious yeah that's me in
that's me
in 1990
probably eight let's look at some other
ones man let's look up uh
let's do bobby lee uh early headshot
you should look at joe diaz have you
seen his early head shots i'm trying to
think if i have or not
his early host his early head shots oh
that one right there that's my wife
bobby i remember
oh wow yeah that's the one wow
look at him he looks like somebody that
works at islands restaurant remember
islands
yeah but he also looks like a guy who
works at islands islands but also gives
hand jobs in the back
but look at not that one but the one
after
look what happens after a couple years
in hell hey like that
that dude looks like he's very different
and look at this one with the guitar go
look at that one
you can see how bad he's doing now i
mean it's so crazy right i mean he's
really changed it up oh kalila took his
nuts you can tell that
he even talked about it in a recent
episode look oh look at this legendary
yeah
oh my god look at that yep my brother
took that picture hold on
look at his slinging dictators yo yeah
dude a hundred percent
oh god bro now all these stories that
makes so much more sense when you see
this guy yeah dude because then now you
see him as this more
agile [ __ ] let's do it all
you know yo so when i met him he was 225
pounds
he would go on stage in a three-piece
suit
um and he paced like crazy really
he paced like and he did this with his
hand all the time
so he made the people in the front row
kind of uncomfortable
because he was an intimidating dude you
know what i mean
um but i will tell you and i and i said
this before
the both joey because i started with
joey ambrody
and um they when they first started and
they were writing jokes
it was almost unbearable but when they
would bomb and ditch their jokes and
just become their selves on stage
yeah they would light up they would
light up the room and
you i watched them gradually progress
into realizing
oh i just got to be myself on stage yeah
especially those two guys
do you know what i mean like though oh
yeah their personalities yeah they're
really yeah i mean
with um with bro let's see brody stevens
early headshot too
brody you had to buy into who he was
right that's the thing
you'd see people who are sitting there
like this guy's horrible yeah and it's
like no you don't
if you knew that in the parking lot he's
he shows up telling people his vitamin
regimen
and how he's been doing yeah um if you
knew that his gpa is something he really
talks about
what he how he did in school at asu yeah
it it makes sense you know what he's 3.6
think about it yeah if you knew that he
just wandered around like that
then you weren't shocked when he got on
stage just keep looking see if you find
anything
i mean if you you know little things
theo like watching him stretch on stage
like kick his leg up yeah because he was
so authentic
to just who he was he got more laughs
off of jokes with more with that didn't
have punch lines than anybody i've ever
known in my life
i mean it was amazing to watch but he
had his own way of
you know he had his uh yeah he just did
his own thing but he yes he became just
they wanted to love him and i think
that's a lot of audiences
it's like they want to get to know this
person that they're going to
see you know and a lot of uh of
comedians
a lot of us we think it's just about the
joke and it's not about
ourselves you know but the crazy part is
it's hard to get comfortable enough on
stage
to get back to just being yourself it's
like this big huge
circle it's like in the beginning you'd
be comfortable by your friends
y'all are comfortable having fun to
lunch table you know people spitting out
milk people's having fun it's fun
you know it's fun and now that's where
you get a little idea in your head man
maybe i'm funny you know and then
you take it on this big circle and
there's no pressure at the lunch table
it's fun
you it's all good you're gonna leave
they're gonna leave y'all going to class
whatever
and i feel like eventually the goal is
to get back to that spot on stage um
i agree with you 100 i think man
the trick for a lot of us is
so when you first start out there are
very few people who are
confident enough to be themselves you
agree
you're some sort of heightened reality
of yourself yeah right
and that heightened reality changes
either in how you talk
and how you like when i was a younger
comic
heightened reality me was louder
moved around a lot more do you know what
i mean oh yeah and so
but but the trick is to hopefully your
audience
allows you to grow and change
and morph into the real you do you know
what i mean
hopefully your audience realizes that as
an artist you're growing also and you're
changing
and i can't be the exact dude i was when
i was 10 years in
because i'm 15 years in now wow and i'm
a different person you know what i mean
and it gets scary as an artist too
because you get stuck thinking okay well
is that just the like is that the only
me is that the best me like how will i
can i shake that is it okay to grow into
myself or is the audience still going to
support
me i think also like if you get an
audience too early
it could be bad if you haven't really
become whoever you're going to be
because then
yeah they're getting this like version
of you that's not really
refined or it's not really a hundred
percent as authentic as you could get
here's a question that came in right
here from someone and this could be
brendan shaw
hey josh theo it's brad from vancouver
canada hey brad
josh question for you what is the uh the
craziest story you have about living
with joey diaz
gang gang gang brother all right i got a
couple questions
first of all did he need to be shirtless
for the question or
i think it makes him feel look i can't
i can't make it through a a good
television program i can't make through
an episode of the wire without taking my
shirt off well yeah but that's personal
you know what i mean that's something
where you're like i feel like i need to
breathe well i just need to yes
i do like the fact that he might have
squeezed his nipple a little bit right
towards the end so i like this dude
that's that nervous habit baby
and here i will tell you uh my favorite
joe diaz stories
come from you know he used to babysit my
kids right
and um did you guys ever do the road
together
yeah man he sold me once for a bag of
weed did he really for sex or what
yo so pre-phones we might have had
pagers
me him and a guy named lenny schmidt
lenny was living in seattle at the time
but he's out of
chicago black guy nope uh irish dude
bring up lenny schmidt i just want to
know visually who we're even thinking
about
um i don't want to be thinking and and
be wrong
that yeah that's there you go there you
go i'll be using joe dirt
oh lenny huh yeah wow there you go lenny
schmidt
so me joe diaz lenny schmidt we drive
down to roseburg
washington we do a one-nighter
um and uh we're out of the bar
afterwards
and we're sitting um as joe diaz called
her he was like
we gonna bring that girl who looks like
me with a wig i'm like yeah we're gonna
she wanted to come i was like yeah we'll
bring him she was driving too you know
so we go to this bar i go to the
bathroom i come back
joey and lenny are gone and i'm sitting
there for a second
and we're talking me and the girl for a
little while and then finally i'm like
where where jo and lenny and she said oh
joey sold you for a bag of weed
and i was like what i thought it was a
joke and
sh because he said where can i get some
weed i don't have a lot of money
and she said i can get you a bag of weed
but you go leave your friend
damn why you're in the while you're in
the john and he said deal
so i come out and i'm like
your property now yeah i was like well i
don't know how that's going to work oh
this is jim crow eric yeah yeah
i was like well i don't know if i'm down
with that you know because she really
look she was not my
that was not my style she was not i and
by the way
i'm not i always dated bigger girls so
big what isn't an issue for me
like i i always said like i like a girl
with a with a big ass i like to see the
wave you know what i mean
i i i have a big mouth so i like my
girls to be a little bigger just in case
there's a fight you know what i mean
yeah and beth is the first girl that i
ever dated that was i like him a little
bigger
so this girl being big wasn't a problem
just the entire situation
you weren't attracted to her yeah yeah
she goes i go let me drive me back to
that hotel she goes oh okay
was she nice was she cool yeah until we
get back to her place oh yeah
now why'd you go to her place i thought
you said hotel okay i go yeah take me
back to hotel she was cool
and i don't know anything about this
place she goes hey i just need to swing
past my
place real quick to get some more weed
for you guys and then i'll
drive you to the hotel and i'm like
perfect more wheat how much you guys
going to smoke i guess you got joey
witch
i figured joey it's gone by the time i
get to the hotel do you know what i mean
that's smoke a motive baby
dude i showed up at that house and we
park
she goes in the room to get weed she
comes out in this
crazy lingerie dancing
like the guy from silence of the lamb oh
yeah you know what i mean yeah yeah but
like
but like let me give you an idea the
the body type like the belly was bigger
than the boobs oh yeah
you know and no booty and so
and and that's that tampa dude that's
that tampa oh yeah
that's that delray beach yeah mom dude
but yeah but i'm gonna go even worse
short curly hair oh yeah yeah you know
what i mean the whole package was not
yeah but she's dancing in this lingerie
and i'm like hey i gotta
yeah yeah i gotta and she goes let me
try something else on she and i was like
no no no
she goes back in and i'm looking for
yellow pages because i'm like i'm going
to call a cab
she comes out with another one she's
running her finger over my cheek at this
point it's feeling
kind of rapey yeah because i'm like
she's definitely
double my weight like i think i could
outrun her but she's got a car
yeah and she's bigger than me yeah and
you can't just run off into the distance
so like this guy there's a buffalo bill
dance her roommate comes home
with her boyfriend he walks in
and i stop at the door i go hey man we
don't know each other but you gotta get
me out of here
okay and he was like what i go i told
him the situation she comes out in her
third outfit
and he looks at her and looks at the
girl's roommate and the girl's roommate
goes you mind your own business
and the guy was like i gotta take him
home i can't i can't do
i can't do this to him no he got coded
me and i was like thanks dude he goes
yeah i may not have sex tonight but i'm
gonna save you i was like dude
thank you so much we didn't drop dude we
didn't talk
on the way to the hotel i just kind of
looked out the window like one tear like
it was
a traumatizing but he dropped me off and
he and we just fist bumped
didn't say anything i walked to the room
i knocked on the door
i go joe diaz and he was like who is it
i go you know what the [ __ ] it is
and i was like give me some that weed he
was like now we smoked we smoked all
that dog
yeah he sold me for weeds was asleep
in my bed ate my food in my room and
then was like hey can you drive
i'm tired but yeah man we
we've done some road gigs together dude
that's awesome and i'm trying to think
if i had a good
road gig story what about the one where
you and i
tried to sell at a convention center oh
man
is that the most embarrassing that shows
just how little we knew
what was happening with stand-up comedy
theo
man that was wild man so i'll i'll start
it so
yeah yeah well josh
josh and his wife who is from lake
charles
was putting on a comedy show
and we'd just been on last comic
standing
and they're like hey we can sell some
tickets
let's do a show down in lake charles
you're from louisiana
best from louisiana yeah let's make it
happen we were just on tv
yeah tv must yeah we're gonna sell this
place yeah
so how many seats was it let's look it
up let's pick up the place the lake
charles convention center yeah
i'm dying to know me too hold on before
you online let's guess you want guests
yes yeah 15 000
no you think i'm gonna guess
oh you might be right i mean it's at the
convention center because cable guy had
just played it
he had wow i'm gonna guess 2600
75 7 500. all right
it maybe it seemed like 1500 because we
only sold
can you show a picture from the stage i
wonder if there's any stage view
that's it wow do you remember how many
people were in those seats dude
so i i remember because yes i could see
each one of them
at one point we asked them all to come
down to the front
you remember so we were gonna do radio
right
so we didn't even have radio planned and
the
convention center called and they were
like are you guys expecting a late rush
of tickets
and i was like you know maybe i go wow
how many do we have sold because it was
the weekend coming up
and they were like we got 179 tickets
and i was like what
and they said yeah and they said we've
brought the curtains as far in as we can
wow but you know what i mean yeah but
you still there's still
4 500 seats exposed
and then here's my favorite part of that
besides the fact that we did the show
for probably if there were 150 people
there
i would be excited i don't think there
were no
some were bought as giveaways i think so
yeah
my favorite part about that theo is that
you know beth
made about 2 000 hats
you remember those hats oh i still got a
box at my house
i give them away on my lives oh i love
that but
there's about it just says fairly normal
and because remember we made that poster
fairly normal comedy tour is that it
yeah yeah yeah we made that po
we made like a fairly normal comedy tour
there's no way there's a poster
that was it that's it right there dude
look at you
wow look at that [ __ ]
august 5th 8 p.m lake charles this was
2006. it should have said everybody who
buys one ticket gets a whole row
look at this dude um
oh this is so terrible
why are you third behind flip schultz i
don't know it's just the whole thing's
cringe
that's it's awesome though i can't i
will tell you man
who who opened the show flip
no no no no amy oh yeah amy claire amy
claire
amy claire opened the show because she
was from we thought oh she's from around
here too
that'll help she'll sell a bunch of
tickets none of us could sell anything
oh ticket uh yeah i mean i think most of
them were you guys as friends and family
all of them yeah it was it was to this
date like
the most humiliating walking out it has
to be the smallest amount of tickets
ever
sold in a large place i can't imagine
there's something smaller 160 tickets in
a
in a convention center yeah in 7 500
seats
and but i will tell you the truth
knowing what stand-up i was doing back
then that's about all it deserved yeah
like i didn't deserve more than a
hundred people
no dude i was telling jokes about pt
cruisers that flippa just bought one and
that was a crazy
that was the tough part of me for the
weekend 14
of my jokes were about um kind of a
homoerotic essence of a pt cruiser car
yep and flip schultz had just gotten one
as like his dream car
or not dream car but he just was pretty
happy yeah and he was happy yeah
so it was like oh man we had also just
got through
on the radio the day before we had just
got through
doing about a half an hour rant on his
hands yeah
really on his skinny little fingers and
how oh my god dude it was like
it was pretty crazy and then he flew in
we had a great time but 150 people was
i got a couple of those hats if you want
a man i wouldn't mind a hat i think
god yeah yeah it's it can't believe it
was 15
years ago 2006.
when do you feel like um i only started
commenting in 2003 yeah
when do you feel like like around what
time with your stand-up
because i think it this happens for
everybody where you feel like oh you
really
sunk into it you're like got it well i
thought about this the other day we were
talking about it at the
at the comedy club i was thinking you
know
i always felt like in the beginning of
stand up it feels like
there's like this tide coming in of like
pressure
from the audience you're like okay i
have to get a joke and there's
you know i got to get another joke and
okay there's a laughing but it's all
like
defensive there's this tide coming in
and you have to like battle it and
battle it
and then eventually over time and you
don't even really notice it
you get up and you don't you're the tide
yeah
so you are putting out the pressure you
are putting out the force
there's nothing coming back in maybe
every now and then there's a little bit
of like a
undercurrent or something of like okay
maybe i should move this along or i'm a
little rusty
but there's it gets to the point where
you're the ocean you're the force
and i think that's that's just what i
noticed over time
and i don't even know when it happened
really i think
you know maybe like there was one point
where i got upset with hollywood
and i just felt well i didn't i don't
know if i got upset i've always kind of
had a chip on my shoulder about
hollywood just because i feel like they
don't put a lot of people
like regular people up in hollywood that
much anymore
i know and it's a lot of nepotism now
it's like this person's
kid now it's just and the kid has no
culture you know
it's just there's no so i think um
i was always trying to like sound like a
perfect guy who would be somewhere you
know oh i'm in the yard next door you
know like just this
thing that would be okay for hollywood
and then at one point i just said
dude i'm just gonna talk about what i
like to
what i know i'm gonna talk about just
the [ __ ] that was around me growing up
and just
the weird people and the [ __ ] that
happened and people
you know they busted a man trying to be
a ghost in our town and just [ __ ] like
that you know just like stories from
home and
um do you feel like your comfort level
when do you feel like when you started
sitting down was also around the same
time you got more comfortable uh no i
don't think so
i think i started sitting down just
because um
i have one story that takes like about
12 minutes and it's kind of better from
a stool
yeah and so i think that's kind of led
to me sitting down i think in the future
i'll probably have to get back on my
feet to really start to feel everything
again yeah
getting older it gets more comfortable
sometimes sitting down too yeah you know
what
was for me like i
it's about nuance like it is about the
performance you know
and as i've gotten older i've really
given myself
more leeway to be experimental on stage
and um so i did one whole tour from a
stool i did
then i did the next year just standing
in front of the mic wow
and then i did one of just moving and so
i was like
it's so interesting now i can tell what
part of the story needs me to be still
and what part of the story needs the
motion because it really
adds to the punch you know what i mean
but if you're always moving or you're
always still
like i really feel like you can figure
out
in your act what parts work better like
that
you know what i mean and to me that
those nuanced parts is what happens when
you get a little older and you've been
doing it a while you're like oh this
this joke's gonna work better if i sit
down for the minute leading up to it and
then stand up for the joke
yeah or sh little [ __ ] like that you
know yeah that comedy nerd stuff
i i've really started to dive into you
know yeah
well you and me are more storytellers i
find you know and there's not a lot of
that these days everything gets real cut
and dried um
and stand up are you and i notice that
you
there was something up there there was
dirty and you said f
d are you do you consider yourself clean
i think i just don't like i try not to
be vulgar right like i noticed it
started just
it i don't know and i probably have a
very bad understanding of
if i am vulgar and then i'm not trying
to be vulgar right
but i don't like i think some stuff if
it feels too graphic to me
it just like i don't know a lot of times
it takes people out of it i feel
you know yeah i feel like if like
there's a lady listening and she hears
uh you know
if she hears me say the [ __ ] or you
know
you know ejaculation or something like
that or ejac
or something sometimes they they shut it
off yeah ejac's a tough one i heard
well ejac is easier yeah you get the
point across yeah
well you know what's interesting you
know i think it has to do with being
authentic right because
i i don't i very rarely do i hear people
get offended by joey
because it's so authentic coming out of
his mouth right and if it's not
authentic to you then i think
it offends people more easily because it
also sounds oh that's a good point do
you know what i mean yeah i'm never
offended by anything joey says because
i'm like that's just
it's like when a white guy says the n
word kind it's like oh it sounds a
little inauthentic yeah you
you're trying a little too
right now i'm gonna actually open up a
select item i haven't seen it yet
but gang i'm interested in this thing
man
you gotta see this beautiful hitter
right here from hood hat
our friends at hood hat are now making
custom caps that's right
i got mine right here man uh they're now
making custom caps made to order
with your neighborhood or city's name on
it
hands down the best snapbacks in the
game they have that mid profile vintage
fit
made from the finest merino wool that's
right
hood hat the essence of your
neighborhood
culture will always be a part of your
dna and hood hat empowers you to tell
the world where you're from
i got my gang buzz mandeville lid and my
gang buzz covington lid
right here i got two of them man on
their website
you can make it exactly how you want it
to fit your brand fit your hood fit your
street name
gang baby go get that from hood hat
just go to hood hat usa or give them a
look on insta at
hood hat usa that's right use
code t-h-e-o-20 for 20
off at checkout that's code t-h-e-o
the number two the number zero for
twenty percent off at checkout
go to hoodhat.com
let's uh oh here we got a question right
here from a young gentleman right here
beautiful fella right here
it looks like the same dude with his
shirt on yeah
with his shirt on right here beautiful
man
hey what's up guys quick question uh
josh park more towards you i got this
little uh
this little swag daddy over here yeah
he's a player
you know he's a stud he's probably gonna
mount a lot when he gets older
respect but uh he's the defiant one
i'm starting not to listen and i know
when he gets older
he's probably a little [ __ ] so i
want to know
you know in this this new world gauge
you can't hit your kids anymore spank
them
so josh what do you you know is there
any other ways to discipline them
i know timeouts for [ __ ] theo
you know we come from a different time
dude you know i'm sure you got spanked
when you're a kid do you actually
think it worked because when i was a kid
i remember i remember the beatings
i don't remember why i got the beaten so
i don't know if i actually learned
anything from it
so i don't know if you guys can give any
help
it'd be appreciative thanks guys gang
and uh yeah man yeah man
yeah man man well here's the deal
for a child that age it's hard for them
to understand
discipline and i
i i firmly believe especially that age
all physical does is instill fear espec
because you have no understanding at
that age you know what i mean
i didn't hit my kids um but i do think
every kid needs to be parented
differently like
if i have three older brothers where all
different people were all responded in
different ways
all my dad had to do to was raise his
voice to me and i was like [ __ ] it that
i am
good like i'm ready to do whatever you
need my brothers weren't that way
i will tell you this for me for my kids
and i think jacob is a good dude man
he's turned out pretty well yeah he
seemed like a really cool guy
um man there are things that they
here's the thing no you don't negotiate
with terrorists
they're all terrorists yeah you don't
keep
giving chances i i i always told my kids
here are the rules
you're not gonna hear me tell you again
and warn you
i just gave you the warning is the rule
so there's you have to know they have to
know oh if this happens
i'm going to get in trouble right and
take everything
phone x you know these this generation
of kids thinks they're so tough
have you seen videos of people getting
their xbox taken or
oh they try to i mean what's that crazy
video where that dude tried to shove the
remote control in his own [ __ ] he was
so mad at his parents for stealing his
they go crazy dude they're not gonna
just take the phone take the xbox they
lose
their mind they don't know what to do no
take what
they love jacob one time defied me
because i told them no vapes man i
better not ever see you with a vape
this you never saw this theo oh
my mom just cancelled my brother's uh
world of warcraft account and he is
freaking out dude
camera
[Applause]
[Applause]
i don't think it's fake because i don't
think kids are that good actors
look how crazy i don't know kids are
willing to be good actors because they
have no idea how
ridiculous stuff looks oh he's naked now
after the shoot
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
come on grab watch this
oh my god
how primal huh
[Applause]
see
[Applause]
no way now this kid needs his ass
this is when you beat a kid yeah man but
all i'm saying is
for me it's just a tantrum it's like a
watching a baby
you know but here's the deal dude so my
son tried to throw a tantrum
at a grocery store once my oldest son
trevor i left him
yeah i go hey man we don't do this in
public
and i go we're leaving he was like i'm
going to leave and i go cool i am
yeah i i got jacob i got my daughter
we got in the car and we drove the [ __ ]
home what time did you get home
oh no no i mean he was eight so i didn't
leave him leave him i drove
oh wow and then i drove back i see and
they were going crazy
like i came back i came back like 20
minutes later yeah the kid's like you're
leaving him yeah and i was like yeah i'm
leaving him
and i go no tantrums this isn't what we
do yeah i remember my my dad left my
my brother for real but but like oh yeah
we got left i mean my mom would be like
yeah i can't come get you
if there was any um gave spankings
i'm trying to think of what else if we
got really left uh
yeah she would be like you know i'm not
coming to pick you up and she'd have to
walk home i remember walking three four
miles to get home
i remember walking when i wanted to go
somewhere a lot of times you know or
taking my bike
you know i biked three four miles um
my brother walked like 11 miles once to
the movie theater
you know which is insane i thought and i
think the girl didn't even show up
oh that is the because the whole way he
was going especially back then
yeah louisiana yeah that first 200 feet
oh he couldn't wait to get in that cool
dark movie theater sitting next to his
girl next to his girl dude
watch a little uh point break oh
oh and you know when he got in that
movie theater he was sweaty it was
chilly
i i i remember uh i feel bad for him
still trying to make out with girls at
movies like when i
dude yeah my thing was i'd invite a girl
and
i would get there and i would get there
i invited girl when it was cold out and
i'd get there early so i'd have to pay
to go in
and then they'd have to pay to go in for
themselves you know oh you weren't
you were going dutch no i i don't know
if i don't know if i was dutch or not
but
i paid and i hope that they would pay
you got in there you're like oh yeah i
waited for you yeah yeah yeah yeah
it was so cold out i also didn't have
money to pay for here
my first girlfriend looked like a boy
anyway bro what was his name
uh her name was susannah and she's very
beautiful
adult woman but at the time she had a
very kind of a masculine energy as a
child
and she your first girlfriend yeah i
think she was
she used to lift me up like i would kiss
her and she would lift me up at the
[ __ ] bus stop and like put my legs
around her waist
like dirty dancing [ __ ]
i was she was taller than me she was
older than me oh really she would
literally lift me up and put my legs
around her waist
yeah and the guys on the bus would show
up and they were all losers none of them
had any
girlfriends you know and they like look
at this
you know i'm like what are you talking
about
it was bad she had you in a little baby
bjorn
facing forward yeah that
yo when i was real young this girl i
must have been in sixth grade this girl
convinced me her name was stephanie and
she was like
because i didn't know what you were
supposed to do with girls and i remember
kissing her and stuff and she was like
tomorrow night you can go up my shirt
but the back and it was still skin you
know
oh yeah so when i would go up the back
of her shirt dude she would make her
little you know what are those fine baby
she would make the one of those your
shoulder blades
yeah she would stick them out so i could
feel it yeah
man so i was like i remember my brother
being like that tit
that's what i told my brother i said
back boobs and he goes that's not a
thing i go
it's the part he was like you have him
too stupid like yeah but they're not
they're not hers they're not on
stephanie
yeah dude i i would go up there and
squeeze those back boobs man dude
i remember yeah this girl that i did it
she wore a bra she even need a bra and
she wore one
and oh man i just remember being in
heat you know how psyched were you that
she had a bra oh
even the boobies just the bra man i
oh what am i even doing around this
she was rich bro and we were so poor i
was so embarrassed man sometimes my mom
would have to take us to the movies mom
had like
the smallest car it was like she had a
ford festival bring that bad cat
up yo this thing
and they had like mercedes or something
and they were like
what color would you even let me see oh
that was it right there boom right there
that was it that was mom's car dude now
let me ask the gray when the gray one
automatic or manual it was automatic
uh manual i do miss the manual i do miss
the
and was it four on the floor like down
here yeah i was on the floor too so it
was five did i was so embarrassed
yo we didn't have a car oh and anything
ran on my tears i felt like
and i feel bad man my mom was just
trying to be a mom but
no i get it man i had no i was just i
love how it says pristine
1993 ford festival somebody's damn that
[ __ ] is ricky
that's sharp oh you could drive that's a
suppository dude
you can fill that thing with xanax and
drive it into your butt
that thing is intense so how much do you
think let's make a guess
prices right rules how much is a 1993
pristine ford festiva going for
i'm gonna say right now in today's
market i'm going to say
7 000. whoa i think you're overshooting
that
i'm going to say you might be right i'm
going to say
30 42.50 37.50
49.99 that's not for the car
are you looking in the car park
that actually i mean it doesn't seem too
far off they have so many
dope older pickup trucks in nashville oh
yeah
around this area i started looking at
him i started thinking about
uh i ended up getting a ford ranger
that's what i got right i saw that
i ended up getting a four ranger but i
thought about getting uh i want i
thought about maybe trying to get one of
those tesla trucks when it comes out
those things look amazing man yeah have
you seen the rivion truck
oh you got to see this well who makes
that um i'm not sure
can you uh sorry sean we got you doing a
million things dude
let me ask you one more question about
your stand stand-up because i'm i'm
i'm as i'm writing more and more
you right on stage are you right here i
write on stage yeah me too and then i
bring it off stage and then i'll
spl spruce it up you know do you when
you
write on your computer do you find that
your jokes are different
than the ones you come up with on stage
you know when you're sprucing it up
right
yeah i find whenever i write whenever i
sit down to write
i don't write jokes the way i talk
so the my best punch lines always come
on stage because i'm
i'm writing the way i talk oh yeah and
then i'll record it then i'll record it
and then rewrite it down yeah
oh got it got it got it yeah i find the
funny thing for me i've had jokes that i
wrote like 10
12 years ago that i've never tried on
stage that i've always wanted to and i'm
still afraid to try them sometimes
so theo this special that i'm doing on
march 4th
i found my very first comedy cd
and i was like let me just listen to
this i made like 20 of them
and i thought there's a bunch of
premises here but i'm going to rewrite
every joke
and redo it really so i didn't punch him
up i rewrote every joke
under the the microscope of who i am now
right
it was such a cool thing man because
a lot of those jokes you know when i
listened to old jokes i would
listen to the cd and i was like oh
that's a good joke but i thought it was
over
like if i got a laugh i was like okay
now i can move on yeah as a younger
comic you're like well i don't need to
dig or you know
and i just found there was so much more
so this the march
4 special that i'm doing is like the one
i'm most excited about that i've ever
done because
it's it's up i've never done this before
i've never rewritten
an entire hour of material do you know
what i mean
yeah under being a better so it comes
out when january 4th
uh on march 4th okay um it streams live
so i'm doing one take
dang one take i'm streaming it live
wow yeah yeah yeah but you know what man
i love that [ __ ] so i like
kind of that fight or flight feeling and
so that really will give it to me
dang bro that's ballsy where are you
guys gonna film it here
wow that's awesome congrats dude thanks
man and and uh yeah you can get the
tickets on my website
comedianjoshwolf.com
and will it be up out online after or no
yeah but we're gonna
obviously we're gonna wait a little bit
because we want people to
here's what i really want man i'm trying
to
show hopefully this is gonna be good for
all of us
because hopefully we don't need
hbo or netflix if we put this up man
and me with my reach i sell a certain
amount of tickets
and i say to you i go theo we may not
need netflix man
i sold this amount of tickets lord knows
what you could sell
yeah and then you own it do you know
what i mean like
right so you're still making the
paycheck that netflix is going to give
you
right but you get everything else on top
of that
and you know the special is going out to
the people who want to see it because
it's your people
right it's it's so i'm really trying
to not upset the apple cart altogether
yeah
but a a good amount of tickets sold will
change the business
it could change the business for all oh
yeah you know i mean look i love that i
love the idea of trying it different
trying something new
trying you know to for to put the power
back in the hands of people you know
it's crazy it's like um
yeah it's crazy how much power that a
lot of
uh these companies and they can flag you
they can take stuff down they can limit
you
they cannot give you opportunities it's
just crazy to think that
um especially since all a lot of the
media is just extremely liberal which is
fine
but it's not fine if that's the if
that's the
judgment because there's gonna become
judgment with that yeah so there's gonna
come judgment against like
certain types of comedians it's like
it's like they're sometimes you could
say they're just letting through what
they want to let through
you know and so that could be a little
bit scary like nobody should be
not have a chance you know because the
guy at the finish line
wants to move the finish line or make it
only for certain people that's crazy
right
and i'm not saying that really applies
here but it's really kind of like
what it feels like sometimes like
hollywood has become you know i think
there's no doubt i think that you know
my content has always been more geared
towards the middle of the country than
it has
like my worst room to perform in the
country for me
consistently is that main room at the
comedy store yeah
easily my hardest room my toughest room
i i'm i'm not and never have been really
one of the cool kids
you know what i mean and it's a cool
that's a cool room man and the people
come down there
are there to see the cool kids and i
feel like my humor is just a little
broader my stories are a little
broader you know what i mean they're
relatable to a large
group of people but not so much on the
coasts and there's been a harder rooms
for me
you know i'm trying to think of what my
hardest room has probably been
you know where i've always had a tough
time man i feel like
is in minneapolis well that you the
house of comedy
yeah those ceilings are thousands of
feet high oh that's insane
yo so those those ceilings
tell us a little because literally i
tried to [ __ ] jump off that thing i
landed on a bounce house
there's so much going on in that mall
yeah it's on the 17th floor
yeah there are penguins in that mall
dude it's insane there's a gun
there's a there's a gun range next to
the weed store yeah
i bought weed and then i went and shot
guns yeah
puff puff pop pop there there there is
and there's that water slide in the mall
where you could when you can
smell the herpes and that that that
place is like you can't go to a water
slide
in a mall unless you want every disease
like yeah you got to cover your eyes get
it on yeah let's get in there man
mouth open let's get into that yeah your
daughter's pregnant but she's only been
on the water slide
your dad's like where have you been
she's like water slide like who's that a
black guy
like no that's at the mall
yeah they got a ice skating rink in
there man they've got things a little
bit of everything yeah yeah i can't
believe you hadn't seen that video of
that
kid with a remote control well here's
why it seemed fake to me
because the brother runs in there sets
it up and then the kid comes in it's
just
it's the exact way you would do
something that was fake the only
and i that was my first anything too
except the kid
i just don't buy that you like i've had
i have
kids just don't buy you go that mental
but do you feel like i feel like he's
always playing to the camera i feel like
a little bit
like he's playing to the game but also
i'm a naysayer
so i would say that i i would say what i
just said
and i love weird [ __ ] so i'm just gonna
believe it yeah yeah you're right you
know what i mean
it is a lot it's more fun for me just to
believe that that kid you know
i love the fact at the end the guy tries
to put the remote into his butt because
it's like
him saying you know what i'm gonna
[ __ ] show them i'm gonna put
something in my own ass yeah yeah yeah
you know
that's how which is a lot i think a lot
of gay young men feel that way too it's
like okay this neighborhood is wrong me
this community hasn't accepted me
i'll show them i'm gonna put something
in my ass i'm gonna go sit on that long
jockey yeah yeah something like
it's just i'm gonna i'm gonna [ __ ]
own i'm gonna control something you know
i'm gonna put direct tv right in my day
you know i'm in a freaking yeah
[Laughter]
i am going
i'm going to watch f is for family on my
damn kidneys
but i got to tell you something though
if that dude could control the remote
control
inside of his butt cheeks oh now we're
talking
yeah if he could like pick channels and
stuff yeah that would be pretty
impressive
this dude vincent jackson must wait man
he had
been dming me which is crazy
really i feel like you've been dming a
lot of people yeah he would just kind of
communicate
uh and he would send a lot of stuff that
i felt like was kind of
wild like links and things you know
like uh just crazy videos sometimes some
of it was a little bit too it was almost
like
why it was like somebody getting hurt or
something you know yeah
um so some of that sometimes i even said
one time i said i don't like that kind
of stuff
um yeah but he seemed like a nice guy i
mean i just messes with him a few times
um but this is so sad man hillsborough
county
sheriff uh tamper radius and discuss the
key findings
autopsy that jackson was suffering from
chronic alcoholism man
let me ask you something man because i i
for sure
i deal with my own depression stuff you
know
it seems like so much of this like the
more i'm aware of it when i re
you read it you're like this just all
feels like
part of mental illness you know what i
mean yeah and like
um especially for guys like this i'm
sure it's harder
when you've been such an alpha masculine
dude
where your body is basically the that
when your brain starts to betray you
that you just might you must not want to
admit it you know what i mean
sure it's hard enough like i i have had
a hard enough time
and i'm not some alpha ultra masculine
dude but for these guys to admit that
their brain is betraying them must be
the hardest step for them
you know that's a good point man i
didn't really i hadn't really thought
about that yeah because it's total
opposite of everything of like the
weight
and the ability and push through it yeah
that [ __ ] yeah push through it
it's total opposite of everything that
they've heard yeah i can't imagine man
and i think
some of the come down of being like a
hero i mean this guy was a
he was great at football i i thought he
was still pl i can't believe he
you know i think it had been five years
since he last played which i found was
kind of amazing but
um you know maybe i wonder if he knew
that i
that i had suffered you know with uh
with
drinking or drugs and maybe that's why
he had reached out to someone i don't
know he never said anything like that
yeah
i just found it kind of interesting
maybe he was just a podcast fan you know
i don't know
um but you know i do find that like um
or podcast listening
people do reach out though you know i
talked to a couple weeks ago or maybe a
couple months ago
on uh fighter in the kit about my
daughter and her being in rehab and all
that stuff
and more people reached out
um and i do find that when when um
and i don't know if it's part of being
in the program or part of being in
recovery
where you know that the more people that
reach out it almost makes that other
person feel
better you know what i mean feeling less
alone i guess oh yeah
and so maybe that's part of thing that
he you know he understood that that's
where you were coming from too and
it just made him feel less alone maybe i
don't [ __ ] know
yeah i don't know i wish he'd have led
some sense you know i i i don't know i
mean yeah like
i'm sure he was communicating with a lot
of dif you know people but he was just
i don't know it's just sad to think that
a guy was at a
you know that had checked into a hotel
and had been there for almost a month it
seemed like or three weeks
um and that he by the way if you're in a
hotel for more than two weeks
something's up yeah more than two weeks
yeah
in the same place in bradenton florida
if you're in a hotel for
more than two weeks i mean look at this
guy this dude is a yeah
physical specimen apparently a really
nice guy i mean
but also how uh the the effect of
alcoholism if you look at it like
he just finished playing five five days
ago
days or five uh five years ago oh yeah
yeah can you put any other information
can you go to another article do you
mind sean
but did they say how he is it say
anything else does it say how he died
let me see one of the jacks was found
dead in a florida hotel room
38 housekeeper dude
you know those house keys anytime i've
been high on drugs or whatever
that's the scariest thought is like that
that's who's gonna come in and think
about that they're a mom they're a
person too you know
and you know it's not like they can just
put you you know sweep you up and then
you know
i mean they gotta probably like rope the
room off now now they got one less room
they're
being able to rent out they've seen some
housekeepers have seen
some [ __ ] yeah we need to get a good
housekeeper on here sean
housekeep i always thought dude a book i
would read tomorrow
is a book just from anonymous
housekeepers talking about
weird things that they've walked in and
found in hotel rooms oh
i'll tell you one right here and r.i.p
vincent jackson man and uh
and just so sorry brother yeah i mean i
just can't imagine him getting stuck
inside of his own head and thinking he
probably couldn't say anything to
anybody
but how fast you have to be drinking for
alcoholism to progress
when you just played football five years
ago i feel like
that's pretty quick yeah because to kill
yourself with alcohol usually takes
quite a long time right maybe i mean i
mean
but i would just i would speculate he
probably couldn't be drinking as much
during his career
so that's what i'm saying like they had
a kid from hometown who just died this
young fella named court
uh named after the play space you know
yeah and he died and he had just drank
himself to death
i mean just crazy and when i think about
i'm like man
yeah he was always drunk every time i
saw him like
yeah that kind of stuff just doesn't end
well man and um
i'll tell you this so one time i had i
was doing
comedy somewhere and a girl
that i've been seeing or some girl i
just met or something
uh and i ended up sleeping in the same
bed right
and i don't remember if we i'll probably
remember
but i just don't i'm either i'm not
sharing if we had sex or if we just made
out or she just slept
over i don't know i don't i don't know
and uh
but in the morning she had gotten her
period
you know while she was asleep menstrual
cycle
so she left okay yeah she left yeah
maybe she won a grammar contest or
something you know maybe she wanted
punctuation
maybe she was maybe punctuation phil had
seen his shadow
you know yeah and it was gonna be uh
she was celebrating but um anyway so
uh i i i went to the
um the cleaning lady
you know and i noticed oh the sheets
have blood on them so i should probably
say something to clean lady it's just
not a nice surprise probably to get
so i went and the lady didn't speak any
english and i didn't know what language
she spoke because i
hadn't really met anybody that had
spoken different languages
so i'm literally like uh
uh and i was just like making a bed like
shape with my hands and then i was like
like uh
[Laughter]
yeah that was pretty wild oh dude so
here's the story so
i heard this story when i first started
comedy so there was a guy
who was a headliner right and he said
well
i was doing a show somewhere i don't
even know where maybe like rochester or
something or
texas and he said after the show some
hot girl
came like beeline for me after the show
because you know like if funny moments
if you do the show then you kind of go
to the bar
yeah you know and so you migrate
especially when like you're just coming
up it's like where you go to like
show your feathers sell some mercy if
there's any ladies
and you're at the bar and you're
pretending that you're like not noticing
who's coming over but you know
oh you're heavily noticed yeah and if
nobody comes over it hurts
a lot so anyway this guy says i'm at
this
i'm at this this lady comes over and
she's like bee-lining for me and she's
like really hot she's really coming on
to me
and immediately she said let's go back
to your hotel
oh she says let's go back to my place
and the guy's like man
you know he's thinking i gotta leave in
the morning or whatever you know let's
go back to my hotel it's close
so they go back to his hotel and they're
kind of kissing and making out a little
bit and like she's like
all over him and she's acting kind of
crazy and she keeps saying let's go
to my place let's go to my place i have
some drugs at my place
so finally uh it gets too much
like the ladies just being like way too
crazy and the guy just kicks her out
says look you gotta
you gotta leave you know like this is
just i don't know what's going on you
gotta leave
so when she's leaving out of the hotel
she sees the feature
that was working there right i guess
he's coming in you know doing whatever
he's been doing eating hot dogs
so she runs into him she says hey
that guy just kicked me out do you want
to come back to my place and the
feature's like yeah
you know this is better than the four
hot dogs that it ate right so
anyway next thing you know they're in a
taxi they get dropped off
it's like about a 15 20 minute drive
it's kind of like out into the burbs you
know out into the woods
they go into the house
they lay they like she like takes him
into this room kind of takes his clothes
off and stuff
um and they do some pills they do some
type of a drug right
and then she like handcuffs him to the
bed and starts giving him a [ __ ]
well uh she passes out
in the middle of the [ __ ] no
so he doesn't know what to do he's
handcuffed to the bed right he's like
what am i even gonna do this before cell
phone so he's like holy [ __ ] i don't
know what to do like i can't even call
9-1-1
some headlights come across the house
like somebody pulling in the driveway
oh no so here's the front door open
a man comes an older man comes
looks in the room sees him there
comes in picks the girl up takes her out
of there
then goes into the kitchen like makes
himself something to eat right
the whole time this dude's freaking the
[ __ ] out right losing his mind
he then the guy comes back into the room
and says this is what he's this is what
he said he goes um
that's my daughter right oh no no no no
and
uh and
i never want you to come over here again
right
then give the dude a [ __ ] bro
the guy did the dad give the dude a
[ __ ] right there
on his penis bro and then then there's
the crazy part
uh took him drove him to a pay phone and
dropped him off and the
dude called the headliner said hey man i
need you to get in a taxi or something
and come get me i need some help
and so he got in a taxi to go get him
and that's where he was
i mean that's the story he told him when
he got in let me tell you something
first of all
i mean that dude takes his job as a
parent a little too seriously
you don't get a pickup where she though
you know what i mean it's not an iou
like
you know
this is where you use a spanking i mean
you don't have to pick up the [ __ ]
for your daughter bro was he like ah
what were you doing blow job all right
so like i it seems like
you know what i mean that's probably
didn't need to that's the gnarly story
i've ever heard
yeah but let me and my second question
is
man i why is this dude getting hard for
for dad like that seems like it could
have been out of fear fear hard
a fear heart a fear boner i think can
you get erections out of fear we look
that up please sean i'm sure
some people love that do you know that
there's a whole
uh porn site where people
like to masturbate but they use tears as
lubricants oh my god
that is like the to me that's
a different let's like it's recycling
but it's too much
yeah it is i like it it's
environmentally i like it but like
here we go an individual has a condition
as a phallophobe
the term is derived from the word fallow
in greek meaning penis and at times
denoting masculinity
dude couple with the suffix phobia so
you said penis
there was a guy who played baseball
against us when i was growing up his
last name was p-e-n-n-i-s
oh wow penis but not in high school your
name wasn't penis
it's a tough yeah man i also had a kid
in my high school named brian o'brien
and when he used to walk down the
hallway we'd go brian o'brien
and he was like [ __ ] you and we'd go
brian oh
brian we had a neil mcneil i was like
your parents just like are not
they don't like you or like yeah that's
too much you can't
name your kid neil mcneal yeah sometimes
neil mcneil yeah that's too much
danny danny we had a guy named danny
danny in our town we had
we had um a couple their names were
jerry and dolly jolly
yeah yeah but some families they like
that romney name
you know where they name all their kids
like a jay oh yeah we had one we had
ronnie
uh ronnie donny johnny lonnie
and uh wait ronnie bungie bonnie
no it was all men ronnie donny lonnie
johnny and tommy
no it had nnie and it was not supposed
to be
oh yeah like a made up brownie yeah like
that yeah like sonia yeah
well you're like that last one you could
tell who was born last you're like we
ran out of
yeah like oh that last one's a risk you
know when um you know i got grandkids
right
and so when my oldest son was like you
have to pick your grandparent name damn
you got grandkids bro i got four
grandkids bro
what you didn't know that we must
protect this house bro i can't believe
you had four grandchildren my oldest son
is 28 man you know
i didn't know that you know he just he
had to he got medically
he got med boarded out of the army in
december like he's just medically he
can't do it anymore
um and so but he's been living in fort
hood in texas
he's moving here really yeah man yeah
yeah yeah yeah
so the grandkids will be here uh he and
his wife are divorced so we'll see them
some but
when he called and asked me he was like
man
what do you want your grandparent your
grandfather named to be i said can you
give me to tomorrow and he said yeah
nice good call
so you choose immediately well i need to
think it out
yeah you know and so beth went with
uh bibi because both of us were like if
somebody calls me grandpa at the park
i'm not looking yeah like yeah do you
know what i mean oh totally
i can't go with grandpa yeah so it's
like if somebody else [ __ ] yeah
yeah you just stay focused you know what
i'm saying bro
don't turn just stay lane bruh it ain't
about you
but when so he okay he calls the next
day
and beth goes i'm gonna go bibi that was
my great grandmother's
name and obviously her name is beth and
easy for the kids pronounced bibi
so my son goes what do you want your
grand father name to be i said
lebron and he went what and i go how
cool
is it to go to bb in the bronze house
yeah bb in the bronze house sounds like
a place sounds like a cartoon yeah i
want to be
and plus i just wanted to be at a park
and hear a kid go lebron
because you know everybody's gonna be
like get the you know what i mean and to
have me run up
and so he said to me he was like you
can't i'm not letting you do that i was
like
and he asked me he said is everything a
joke with you i was like
yeah are you new like you've been in
this family
you thought i was going to pick like
papa or some [ __ ] like that like
what would be a secondary when though jj
is kind of cute i want jojo jojo is good
we're bb and jojo oh i like that yeah
we're like an older child
a plane crasher or somebody chokes on a
sandwich i feel like yeah
yeah it also kind of sounds like a
sandwich the bb and jojo sandwich
yeah i like that i like bb jojo do you
see what's the uh thing that happened in
uh texas with that governor did you see
that the mayor wrote that note
texas mayor tells residents can you zoom
in there you thank you
by tuesday morning the residents of
colorado city texas were getting anxious
more than 24 hours had passed since a
deadly arctic blast knocked out power
across the state
residents turned to a community facebook
group to ask whether the small town plan
to open warming shelters while others
wondered if
firefighters could do their job without
water colorado's mayor chimed
in um lesson comforting message
he said no one owes you or your family
anything mayor tim boyd wrote i'm sick
and tired of people looking for a damn
handout
what uh that the lazy residents find
their own ways of procuring water and
electricity immediately drew backlash
later on tuesday boyd announced his
resignation and admitted he could have
used better words how do you
procure electricity like what
right okay uh highlight have one of the
worst winter storms in decades is
testing the limits
of the embrace of self-sufficiency and
rugged individualism in texas
so it's a good question man like i don't
know you know i was thinking about this
the other day
um so will you grab me an extra water by
chance thanks man
um how would you do survival well i was
thinking about this the other day so
i'm talking to my friend in louisiana
and he said oh there's rolling blackouts
so
some friends are coming over tonight
because we have power tonight right i
said okay that's interesting so
it made me think like what if the power
company i'll take the death
so thanks brother so what if the power
company like
like the power company is not a
guarantee for like it's a it's part of
society that we've gotten to we're lucky
enough to have like this thing this
structure you know but yeah like what if
it went out like
so i don't know where this mirror was
coming from i mean that's probably
certainly the best way to word things if
you're the leader
but i mean if it's people sitting in a
home they're freezing to death yeah and
it's
you know at some point you have to start
a fire for yourself or you have to go to
somebody's house that like you have to
also take action
true but you don't want your leader to
be like every man for himself
that's basically not the message you
know what i mean but that's a great
point you know your leader is supposed
to be your leader let everybody else
panic
but if you're panicking it's it's over
you know
but it's one thing to tell people to get
water because there's snow outside so
you know
there's moisture you can figure that out
procure your own electricity
look i mean i wouldn't even if i would
first of all i might have to google
procure
i don't know exactly what it means i
think i do i think it's how you treat
ham yeah
get that back open yeah let's go back to
the yeah
uh at least 10 deaths in texas have been
linked to the winter storm since monday
according to eastern chronicle
so yeah i mean it's wild i think i think
maybe this guy was probably just
upset about other stuff and probably
attached it to this
yeah but if you were going to procure
your own electricity what would be your
first move i'd probably get a generator
gas power generator or i would start
burning stuff
i mean it's tough that's why burn it
outside because this
the storm is obviously gonna oh that's a
good point but you can't burn it inside
either because of the gas
yeah yeah you know what i mean so the
heat that's the thing that i
i don't know exactly how people were
doing it unless you had
the generator right so yeah i think
that's a good point so i guess maybe
they're thinking yeah find other people
that have generators
i get it's also tough with this kind of
article you don't know if people's cell
phones are still working you don't know
if the roads are able that people
can drive on um i wish they knew they
would say what set this man off
but yeah if you're the leader i think
you probably gotta find a better way to
lead
yeah you can't you can't come out and be
like hey you [ __ ]
[Laughter]
procure some electricity i'm like well i
don't even know what that means man
i don't have any electricity to google
procure so you're gonna have to break it
down for me a little better yeah but if
you're in your house yelling
for help but you also have legs at work
it's like
then that's on you also but i think one
of the big
issues we have in america today theo is
that people have
forgotten that two things can be true at
the same time
yeah two things can be true at the same
time you know whether you're talking
about
this pandemic where two things can be
true at the same time
do masks cure everything no they don't
you can still get it if you have a mask
yeah
but is it possible that they help yeah
right so there's two things people are
saying you're yelling at each other and
both of what you and i are saying
are the same are true you know what i
mean it's possible for two things to be
true
this also should you wait to die
no but is it up to you to procure
electricity
yeah probably not not at first yeah do
you know what i mean like so i think
it's probably
that's the thing like we've we've
lost the ability to go yeah that can be
true what i'm saying is also true but
that can be true also
yeah there's no there's no room for two
sets of truths
right which most things have yeah most
things have
two sides and most of the time both
sides have truth to them
yeah that's why people are so it's so
easy to to pick a side now right we're
so tribal now
it's not that there aren't we can't find
facts there are too many facts available
yeah so i can find a fact that'll back
up whatever the [ __ ] i want to tell you
is true
i can find a fact online an article
online a news site online
that'll back me up you know what that
does that makes me seem smart that gives
me a [ __ ] hill to stand on
so i never have to listen to you oh yeah
do you know what i mean i just saw it
online
and everybody in your echo chamber says
the same thing so it must be true
but both two things can be true at the
same time yeah that's a good point man
ability to see
um they just had this ufc girl that lost
her job did you see this this carano
girl
yeah man as a jew i think it's not good
yeah what did you have any thoughts on
it man look i think
the equivalent is a complete false
equivalency
of her what she's making here a complete
false equivalency the fact that
she has said some things that upset
people
and are going out there going after her
online is
not even close to what jews had to deal
with
in the 40s in germany oh yeah it's it's
not
even it's a however
the this is we we have to stop
cancelling people for having different
ideas than we have
yeah that's it even if their ideas are
wrong even if their ideas are deemed
wrong yeah it's like it's gotten to this
place where it's like
if somebody because then you end up with
a herd of people who will just never say
anything but they're angry all the time
right
and so look it's nick cannon to me was
the best example
when i heard what he said i was like oh
this dude
just doesn't get he doesn't know yeah
he's yeah he's just reading like
somebody he watched some bad
uh malcolm x he's regurgitating some
some false narratives and i'm not saying
malcolm x is bad i'm saying he watched
some outtake of farrakhan or something
like
there's some videos that get passed
around even by smart people that i know
that i'm like
are you serious just sharing this i i
dude i could not agree with you one that
goes around it's like that oh
uh white people are afraid if black
people got in power that they would
treat
white people like they treated black
people and i'm like this is insane
i haven't seen that one is that a fair
con one yeah i think it was a fair
comment but just some of the stuff that
like
i don't know just like it's just so like
i
i don't know i just i can't believe some
people would
share some things that they share you
know i i just think this scene
probably first of all unnecessary i
think if you feel like
you can't be heard which i think you can
if you have
if you have like it's not even if you're
not like
almost openly because they had that
silence is violence thing
like during blm like if you're not
openly
liberal a lot of times i feel like you
definitely get stared at
for not making a lot of the same
statements you know um
this here's the thing man but like
we we're making people scared
to speak so you drive people underground
yeah and when you drive people
underground
what happens is they get angrier and
angrier and angrier and angrier
and then it probably erupts in something
like this and then something happens and
then something happens
and for me like look nick cannon was the
perfect example
when i read it i'm like this dude just
needs to be take him to auschwitz
take him to the places that can show him
exactly
what he's not hearing about this history
right and
and by the way somebody did i think
julian edelman that dude from the
patriots jew i believe he's the one who
took
might have taken nick canada auschwitz
and sat down introduced him to some
rabbis
and the rabbis were like here's the
history of jews and nick cannon was like
got it
got it right and um but we've stopped
even allowing that julian edelman goes
at nick wright on twitter
no we've stopped allowing there to be
i've always said the number one way you
learn something is by someone really
showing you by hand yeah and instead of
like people offering to do that now
they uh they take people's jobs away
they denounce them they make them
i don't know they like they i guess they
canceled them like i feel like yeah
maybe it's better if someone says
i think you don't understand some things
dude some people
are racist and it's hard to get through
there and some people are just
ignorant to it and angering i don't mean
that in a way they're ignorant people
but they're
about this thing yes i don't mean that
in a negative way right so
to me you know julian edelman
getting in there with nick cannon and
nick cannon meeting with rabbis that's
education
right and so what that does is when you
cancel him you make him angry
he hates jews more that's it's their
fault i lost my job
right and he perpetuates it and instead
of that it stops there hopefully
and so and a guy with a good with a loud
microphone can be like hey this is
actually the way it is now yeah
there are some people i just don't think
you reach oh and by the way from cool
hand luke some
people you just can't reach oh yeah so
you so you get what you had here last
week
yeah um but but i think man that
it's all about being able to sit down
and talk to people
yeah because canceling people gets it
doesn't do it i think it's also
losing some of its appeal and it's
making people really turn away from a
lot of hollywood it's like
so with these people just cancel anyone
who like and it's not in this instance
you know i mean this is
i mean you know it's like some of this
seems pretty intense
but she must have felt for a long time
like she can't say anything yeah she
can't speak
um look i don't agree with a lot of the
things that she's posted
and i don't think any of them mean that
she should have been
cancelled off that show yeah i just
don't think that's the right message to
send
again when you're pushing a group of
people underground
because they think differently than you
that is dangerous that's how you have
uprisings that's how you get a bunch of
angry people
fighting back because whether it's true
or not look man it's perception
your perception of how things is are is
your reality
right whether it is reality or not right
so if you have say two million people
who feel like they're being persecuted
whether they are they aren't and being
pushed under the ground where they are
they aren't
it's going to bubble up there's no way
for it not to yeah
and so i just feel like we're going
about this
in the wrong way a lot of times there's
some people who do deserve to get
canceled oh yeah i think there's some
people who are yeah there's people who
you know there's people all over the
place that probably deserve uh
probably is definitely some sort of ca
some sort of reprimanding some sort of
real
yes action against them you know um
but it is it's definitely like it's
become a place a lot of
social media has become a place where
you can't it's not even like
it's like they group everybody i feel
like there's a lot of grouping of
white and poor white people that um
they're all racist or they're all this
way or they're all
dumb or they're all ignorant it's like
man it's so hard to be poor and white
like don't you understand like
i think it's hard to be poor dude in
anything white is one color of poor
get treated differently by the media
than another color does man that just
baffles me sometimes well i just think
that and i grew up poor too man like we
grew up in no car
and you know um i remember walking to
school and we just rode our bikes and we
had to borrow a car to go grocery
shopping and
you know um i wore hand-me-downs
because i had three older brothers damn
i wore hand-me-downs until i was like
12 or 13. they started off as overalls
and they finished his pants yeah man i i
mean i didn't have like you know what i
mean
so i get it i just think that
it's not that white poor people are
treated differently
i just think they're not portrayed at
all
like it's the they haven't been for a
while visually
visually we're not being asked to
feel sorry for or support that community
yeah and i i don't know the exact reason
for it man you know and i i think
all media is unfortunately
intentionally divisive because i think
fear
motivates people to do things more than
anything else
the thing that's going to motivate you
to do something the most is for me to
get on camera
and say hey everybody these people this
group of bad people are coming to take
something away from you
something you already have nothing
motivates you to do something
then somebody come to take some [ __ ] i
already have do you know what i mean
that'll get you scared guns rights
whatever it is that you're coming to get
think about this dude yeah think about
the mask
and i'm just using this because it's
current and and for me guys
i'm i i fall right in the middle of it i
wear it because i think
e i don't think i'm going to die from
corona but you know what i don't want
whatever the [ __ ] those people are
having because it sounds terrible yeah
two weeks of that sounds terrible
yeah yeah i agree so so and do i have
underlying health issues
i don't think so but i also know other
people that do
and the mask is no big deal to me but
here is how crazy people get
so it's all about um my rights my rights
my rights right
okay hey man make sure you put your
shoes on before you come in the
restaurant okay
hey man make sure you put that shirt on
before you come to the restaurant okay
why
because these are old rules nothing's
being taken away from us
i grew up with them i see what you're
saying they're rules that you've i grew
up with that
so it just seems totally normal to me
but why is it
any different so what i'm saying is
if you said to me hey you can go into a
restaurant with people wearing masks and
no shoes
or shoes and no masks i'd be like no
shoes because i'm not going to get
i'm not getting sick but it's just an ir
a reasonable
law rule that was already there that we
all
already accept right but now that i'm
telling you you've got to do it
now it's my rights do you know what i
mean yeah it's interesting yeah it's
because you're taking yeah you're taking
something away from me that i've always
just taken for granted
now obviously that's not the whole thing
but that is got to do
with it you're taking it from me that's
a part of it yeah that's definitely a
part of a lot of things i think yeah
it's like you're taking something away
from me it's like
yeah um just think of the seat belt dude
the seat belt is something the
government makes you do
because they're telling you it's better
for you yeah
i don't there's nobody like hey [ __ ] you
in your seat belts
yeah you know what you know what i mean
ah that can they can't make me wear a
seatbelt well yeah they can
yeah and you've just accepted it yeah
it's just different man when you start
to get things
changed or taken from you that you feel
like you should have a choice over
it it'll [ __ ] with you as an adult yeah
it does i think and especially as you're
as you become an adult because those are
things you're used to yeah it's just
like
yeah and then you start to feel like if
i lose this and it's going to be other
things
and when does this kind of stop 100 um
100
yeah it's interesting with the mass
thing man it's really interesting i
think
the tough part for me sometimes is when
i have to be like
in a doctor's office or in a place where
you have to keep it on the whole time
and then it's like it starts to be like
you lose the ability to
you don't even feel human a lot of times
you just like you're stuck in this thing
and they're stuck in that thing
and you're just kind of getting done
whatever business you need to get done
100 and there's no value
in like uh being like a human anymore
and then i think
you attach that if you then attach that
to the fact that there is um
you know that that the government is
mandating it and that like
you know it's uh instead of just letting
the the disease pass through
like herd immunity type of thing they're
like
trying to like mandate everyone's
movements and everything
it's scary for some people when the
government starts to step in
and tell you what you should or
shouldn't do
my whole thing with this and basically
whatever you want to use whatever
example climate change or anything right
i'm not very smart so what i do
is i go okay what do the majority of
smart people say
if the majority of smart people were
like hey
if the majority of doctors said hey
daddy don't don't wear the mask i'd be
like yeah everybody don't wear the mask
and some say don't wear the mask but to
the doctors that i've spoken to
the majority of them are like yeah just
wear the mask it's probably easier so
i'm just listening to what
the majority of people who are smarter
than me think right well i'm going to
tell you right now you know what i know
about the disease
no no i don't know
[ __ ] about it i just know the same
articles that you've read
yeah so i just ask people who are
smarter than me and that's all i can do
because i'm not that [ __ ] smart so
when i hear people like you know
what it is dude come on man like you
you know what i mean like it's tough to
like yeah
mustard on your face dude
you don't want to get to that level and
it's also like we're at an age where we
are not like suscept we're not
like the primary candidates of people
that are going to get injured or
something
um i do think it's crazy sometimes how
every place it's like lock up the ground
it's like
put old people on the side and i think
open things up and let people live their
lives
it's crazy to me how a place like
tennessee will be open
and a place like los angeles will be
closed i know there's a lot more people
in los angeles yeah
but it's still not like it's rampant
in tennessee you know i think the
problem
has been we're all we're all
you know you go back to it if we go back
to what talking about the kids
if we all consider us kids right
consistency
there's never been a consistent message
yeah which has
sowed basic distrust into
now every since there's never been a
consistent message and it's never been
consistent
in the places in the country everybody's
like well nobody knows [ __ ]
so i'm coming up with my own idea you
know and at this point
we're too far in to shut it down again
oh i agree with that you know what i
mean i agree if it was gonna happen
it everybody should have been put their
big boy pants on for those first two
months
but after the first two months it's out
there
but i feel like the first two weeks
everybody was locked up
you know maybe they weren't what maybe
they weren't i don't know
you know what's interesting man for me
it definitely feels like to me that
things should be open
and we should keep real good care of our
senior citizens give them some money
so that they're able to take care of
themselves yeah and let everybody else
go back to work man
that's what it feels like to me i um
i talked to my dad can i tell you what
my dad said yeah he's 83.
and um it's a couple months ago and i
was
and he's you know my dad is a
my dad is the most honest
moral ethical dude and um
but i asked him i go so uh what do you
think about maybe we should just start
the economy and
i'm thinking about maybe hitting the
road a little bit i just need i can't
not work that i just i can't go another
year with not working
and i could hear him just steaming and i
was like what's going on and he said
well let me ask you something
have i lived my life pretty well and i
go yeah and he goes i raise my kids and
i'm definitely not at the beginning of
my life is that right and i said yeah
and he goes
so i because you can't figure out
your [ __ ] i have to live the rest of my
life indoors is that you're telling me
i don't deserve the respect like i
haven't lived my life i didn't
the rest of people my age we didn't
build this country for you guys that we
have to live our last years
indoors because you can't figure out how
not to go to a [ __ ] bar on a friday
and i was like and i said i
completely understand that i go but what
about the small business dude
in new jersey who's been shut down for
seven months and he goes no i get that
he said but you can't just open it up
wide
we got to be smarter he said because i
don't want to die in my house
yeah and i was like i and i couldn't
remember how we were talking about two
things can be true at the same time
yeah i couldn't argue with that do you
know what i mean because yeah i know you
it's tough to yeah what are you gonna
say to that man
so like you know his life is his real
his is his reality and it makes perfect
sense
yeah yeah um so for me i'm with you like
we just got to figure out a way you can
still be smart
you know those 27 man orgies maybe stop
there's been a couple of those you see
really getting busted oh man
dude there was 125 man there's dude
apologize
show up
yo with 25 dude orgy that's a lot
of ticks to worry about man that's this
one
this guy got caught sneaking out of the
back oh definitely he did
he got caught sneaking out of the back
of a 25 due to orgy because he's an
anti-lgbtq politician from hungary
but he got he got so his anti-lgbtq
and he got busted and that's always how
they do it yeah coming out of 25 guys
first of all gays wear some dicks where
yeah how do you pick your 25
you know what i mean like how do you
pick and is 25 the limit two of them
right there in the distance right there
yeah
yeah this dude now that's a lot of men
are lead you know without ladies out
there we gotta at least let the ladies
loose
man look at this guy it looks like if
i'm picturing 25 dudes who look exactly
like that dude right there you know what
i mean
just oh man just playing [ __ ] booty
darts this dude
this dude when he has sex he his face
gets sweaty
there's no doubt this dude's face gets
sweaty i bet he keeps his shirt on
during
the whole time that white t-shirt yeah i
bet he keeps his watch on
oh yeah what time time for me to keep
[ __ ] yeah but i think he goes
when he goes sex he goes glasses off but
he puts one monocle in
yeah monocle sweaty face white t-shirt
and socks
yeah he should definitely at least sell
merch
how do you [ __ ] that's the problem
bro if you were
elected official when you get busted in
a sex crime sell
murder you gotta march it out man how
are y'all not selling merch
i mean that that seems like i mean
what's the t-shirt you wearing
jumping out of a 25 dude yeah orgy
yeah it's just like a bit a picture of
you like leaving a house and there's
like 20
25 sets of eyes and one of them was
peeking on one of the windows or how
about
i went to a 25 man orgy and all i got
was this lousy t-shirt
that's the one to do it all right you
win the shirt idea yeah
let's bring up another news article what
else do we have and then we'll finish up
here man
uh let's go with that uh logan paul
what's he doing now did he sell his home
does it say what does it say here
can you zoom in a little thank you
brother the pandemic has filled a
dramatic new wave of high profile
migration
sending tech workers to texas wall
street types to florida
and youtube provocateur logan paul to
puerto rico paul and influence
entertainers told his 2.8 million
youtube subscribers tuesday he was
leaving los angeles and moving to the
heaven on earth of dorado
so it to me this is a community about 30
minutes west of san juan has become a
favorite spot of wealthy
mainlanders to me uh this
sounds like he did
ayahuasca and just took off and went to
portland now he's making a choice he had
now
yeah um i gotta tell you you know um
i first of all love puerto rico it's a
beautiful place
but i understand they have some weather
issues down there where you might not
want to build a
super expensive home yeah because the
hurricanes whip through there
pretty good however um you know
it's a beautiful spot oh yeah portugal's
beautiful man they got that three kings
day
tres reyes tres reyes which is also a
gang uh
in part of america but it's crazy here
in california paying taxes and for what
paul said on his show impulsive the
streets are not fixed homeless people
everywhere
a darth well i'm surprised you knew that
word but i respect that logan well done
a darth of unemployment coveted not
handled
i don't love it yeah man there's a lot
of things about california that lead it
to
that i think have led to some of its
decline
in some of our minds i mean for me
number one was definitely taxes
yeah i just didn't feel like paying
taxes to uh
just such a a place that to me it just
becomes so
just too far lopsided just i agree out
for blood
not as creative as it as i felt like it
maybe once was um too much
nepotism i feel like not enough chances
for the regular person that's moving
there
um and i could be wrong i i could be
totally wrong but those are just
thoughts that have been in my head
no am i saying they're accurate for me
the taxes i was like i i didn't mind
paying the taxes
when i knew what my taxes were going
towards right
why am i paying taxes and stepping over
homeless people wherever not it's not
just in one part of the city now
everywhere why am i why am i meeting up
yeah man
they're making community yeah why am i
paying taxes
and it's so dirty do you know what i
mean like if i'm paying this money
it's a lot of money yeah a lot of money
then what am i getting from
it and i wasn't getting anything and not
only that man honestly
it's like i said and i should have left
a couple years ago i never felt like i
was really part of the cool
kids and i felt like i feel so much more
creative and relaxed here because i
don't feel like i'm
competing all the time oh yeah i'm not
waking up wondering what other people
are doing or
a great point you know what i mean yeah
that part of my day is gone
it's like i'm just a little creative and
maybe i can spend some time taking care
of myself yeah
um did you wake up also and worry about
what other people were doing and what
other people
i just found like i'm i'm like why am i
in my own head
competing with these people yeah we're
not competing
do you know what i mean right i haven't
done that here
yeah i think uh i think well
i stole my apartment there so it's like
and i'll probably go back and spend some
time there especially
as the summer comes back and um and it's
a nice you know to get to the beach and
also to do
do podcasting and stuff like that but
it's nice to not
have it just never felt like it always
felt like work
it felt like the second i got off the
plane i was at the office
okay just like man i'm at this and then
if i was if i was
home for two weeks i'm i'm just in an
office for two weeks rather i'm sleeping
i'm at the in my bed at home or anywhere
i am
just always like this never-ending buzz
of uh of office stuff and then i
i really feel like some of the
creativity there has
they've it's been so separated it's like
so second third fourth generation just
people getting opportunities on their
name and stuff
that they've lost sight of like a lot of
the
not only lost sight but kind of
separated themselves from a lot of the
places in america where a lot of good
storytelling comes from and like
um you know in a lot of creativity like
creativity is kind of a group process
you know and when you
when you really minimalize yourself to
very
you know kind of narrow
lanes of okay thought i think
and i'm not saying if they're right or
wrong but it it very much
leaves you in this place where you can't
really tell a joke if there's no
if there's not a wall to bounce it off
of sometimes and it's like
they just have created this place where
i don't even you see some of these new
comedy shows and comedy specials and
it's like there's not even any jokes in
it it's not comedy
no it's not it's not comedy it's crazy
and i don't know how they get out of
that
how they get out of this like spiral of
oh you're worse than i am
you're you messed up you messed up you
messed up you're bad
you know it's it i i think podcast has
helped stand up more than anything
because no doubt it's a loud man right
because people have gotten used to
remember when people used to talk to us
about jokes per minute
we got to be yeah well there's not
enough time 70 jokes per minute yeah
there's none of jokes per minute in that
story you're like
but i'm telling a story like it's got to
be so i really feel like it has helped
but i think what started happening in
l.a for me
anyways is that everybody kind of looked
at joe
or segura or you or bert and it
it it um the
path to success started to become very
repetitious it's very copycat
and so i think a lot of the creativity
ha it's like you know a couple years ago
maybe 10 years ago everybody who left
new york comedy scene sounded like a
tell
everybody had his cadence yeah do you
know what i mean not because they were
ripping it off but he
was that big of an influence right and
so i think there's so much of the
influence from the top
that creatively a lot of the stuff
that's coming out
is starting to look the same we haven't
had that next wave
of who's doing something different
interesting you know what i mean so
right and i wonder if
there's and maybe something different
does come out of a lot of this it
usually always does yeah i think so
i think right you're right
um josh wolf he's got a new special on
march 4th streaming it live one take
dude dang that's risky bro but it's
gonna live
for a week uh so if you get if you can't
watch it on thursday march 4th
it'll live for a week on that link it's
only ten dollars
we're trying to we're great deal yeah
and we're upset in the apple cart here
everybody
i like it i like somebody changing the
game man if this goes well then who
knows we could all be doing this so
that's exciting
yeah man and you get to set your own
price it lives for as long as you want
it to live and then you
own the material so you get to do what
you want to do oh i feel you man i feel
you man i have a special with netflix
but then after that i think i would
i think this might be the future you
know yeah and it's nice to see you uh
you know neil armstrong and out there
man yeah comedian joshuawolf.com
everybody don't pay no attention that
picture i'm gonna have to get a new one
yeah we'll see
holy [ __ ] we'll see you guys now i'm
just floating
on the breeze and i feel like these
leaves i must be
[Music]
[Music]
but it's gonna take a little
time for me to set that parking brake
and let myself on my heart
shine that light on me
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a
[Music]
now